hello everyone
welcome to this live session on data
analysis using python and sql by simply
loan in this video you will learn the
important python libraries and sql
commands to perform data analysis data
manipulation data visualization and
exploratory data analysis
our highly experienced instructors will
take you through this course but before
we begin make sure to hit the subscribe
button to stay updated with all the
latest tech videos
so we will start by learning the basics
of data analytics the applications and
the steps involved in the analytics
process you will also look at a key
study by walmart to understand how
walmart uses data analytics to solve
business problems
then
you will learn the important python
libraries to perform data cleaning
numerical computations data analysis
statistical analysis
and data visualization so we look at
numpy
pandas matplotlib libraries and python
you will understand how to perform
explorative data analysis using the uber
data set
after that we'll jump into learning the
basics of sql to store data update data
delete and retrieve data as well as
analyze data by writing sql queries you
will see how to join data stored in
multiple tables understand sub queries
stored procedures and window functions
finally
you will learn how to analyze data in
sql with python programming so let's
begin
welcome to data analytics using python
so we're going to cover data analytics
with python we're going to go over what
is data analytics applications of data
analytics
types of data analytics
data analytics process steps why python
for data analytics and then we'll dive
into use case demos you can actually see
some script and actually see what it
looks like in the python code
what is data analytics
data analytics is a process of exploring
and analyzing large datasets to make
predictions and help data-driven
decision-making now the definition of
large datasets keeps changing and so
this can range
really from just about anything to
anything
but usually in today's world we're
talking significantly larger amounts of
data that you can't just glance at and
try to figure it out yourself
and the two steps are analyze the data
and then make decisions based on the
data
applications of data analytics
now the sky's a limit on this in today's
world almost every business act of life
your music on your spotify are driven by
data analytics
but some of the big players when you go
in their job hunting are going to be
your fraud analysis
if you want to go make a lot of money
and you're good at it and you like
dealing with numbers uh go join the
banks and track down the criminals who
are stealing money it's a lot of you
know it's a big thing to protect credit
cards
protect sales purchases bad checks any
of those things when you can track them
down is huge
healthcare exploding
there is everything from trying to find
cures for
the covet virus or any of the viruses
out there
using your cell phone to diagnose
different ailments
that way you don't have to go and see
the doctor you can actually just go in
there and take a picture of the funky
growth on your arm hopefully it's not
too big
and then they send it in there and the
data analytics goes in there looks at it
and says oh this is what this is this is
a professional you need to go see or
don't need to see
and that's just one aspect of healthcare
the databases being generated by
healthcare and getting the right doctors
and helping the doctors analyze whether
something is
benign or malignant if it's cancerous
all those things are now part of the
ongoing healthcare growth in data
analytics
inventory management
think one of those huge warehouses where
they're shipping out all the goods
how do you inventory that in such a way
so that
you maximize the stuff that's being
purchased the most near the entrance and
all the other stuff towards the back or
even pre-ship it
uh so it's huge to be able to inventory
the
manager inventory and pretty soon
they'll just have a drone come in there
and start picking up some of those boxes
and move them around also
deliver your logistics again this goes
from getting from point a to point b
you can combine it with our inventory so
you pre-ship stuff if you know a certain
area is more likely to purchase it how
do you get it the delivery to the most
destinations the quickest in the short
amount of time and then they even
pre-stack the trucks going out and
that's all done with data analytics how
do we stack all that stuff so it comes
out in the right order
targeted marketing huge industry any
kind of marketing whether you're
generating uh the right content for the
marketing who are you targeting with
that marketing
researching the people what they want so
you know what products to market out
there all those things are huge
and these are just a few examples you
can probably go way beyond this from
tracking forest fires
to
astrology and studying the stars all of
this is part of data analytics now and
plays a huge role in all these different
areas
city planning is another one
you know you can see a nice organized
city like this one where you can get in
and out of the neighborhoods if you're a
fire truck
police officers need to be able to get
in and out you want your tourists to be
able to come in you still want the place
to look nice and you have the right
commercial development the right
industrial development like enough
residents for people to stay all those
things are part of your city planning
again huge in data analytics
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
and this can be broken up in so many
ways but we're going to start with
looking at the most basic questions that
you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight
how many cells per call ratio coming out
of the call center
if we have 500 tourists in a forest and
you have a certain temperature how many
fires were started how many times did
the police have to show up to certain
houses
all that's descriptive
the next one is predictive predictive
analytics is what will happen next we
want to predict uh this is great if you
have a ice cream store and you want to
predict how many people to work at the
ice cream store in a certain day based
on the temperature coming up in the time
of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get
pre-scriptive analytics
how can we make it happen
foresight what can we change to make
this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in city development there's a
good one
if we want to have our city generate
more income
and we want that income to be commercial
based
what kind of commercial buildings do we
need to build in that area that are
going to bring people over do we need
huge warehouse sales costco sales
buildings or do we need little mom pod
joints that are going to bring in
people from the country to come shop
there or do you want an industrial setup
what do you need to bring that industry
in there is our car industry available
in that area if it's not a car industry
what other industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it what can we do to fix crime in
area with education what kind of
education are we going to use to help
people understand what's going on so
that we lower the rate of crime and we
help our communities grow better that's
all prescriptive it's all guessing we
want foresight into how can we make it
happen how can we make this better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager
shareholder or the
data scientist coming in you really need
to understand the descriptive analytics
where you're studying the total units of
furniture sold and the profit that was
made in the past
here we go into predictive analytics
predicting the total units that would
sell and the profit we can expect in the
future
gear up for how many employees we need
how much money we're going to make
and prescriptive analytics finding ways
to improve the sales and the profit so
we can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
data analytics process steps
so let's take a look at some of the
basic processing and what that looks
like when you're working with this data
so there's five basic steps the five
steps of processing and this changes and
then there's a lot of things that go on
when they talk about
agile programming
the whole concept of agile is you take
some kind of framework like this
and then you build on it depending on
what your business needs
so the first step is data collection
and usually with a large company you
might have somebody who
is responsible for the database
management
you may have another one where they're
pulling apis and they're pulling data
off of maybe the census bureau
maybe something very very
specific domain specific so if you're
analyzing cancerous growths and how to
understand them then the data collection
is going to be those measurements they
take from the mri or it might be even
the mri images they've used those also
so there's a lot of things with data
collection and how to
control that and make sure it has what
you need and is clean and you don't have
miss information coming in
once you have the data collected there's
a data preparation
so stage two is we take that data and we
format it into something we can use
probably one of the biggest formats that
you see is when you're processing text
how do you process text well you use
what they call a one hot encoder and
each word is represented uh by a yes no
kind of setup so it'd be like a long
array of bits
that's one way to prepare it and so you
know bit number one is the bit number
two is has or whatever it is
other preparations might be if you're
using neural networks you might be
taking integers or float numbers and
converting them to a value between zero
and one
that way you don't have one of them
creating a bias in there so there's a
lot of different things that go into
data preparation
that is eighty 80
of data science so when we talk about
the data analytics which is a little bit
more on the math side and they usually
say talk about a data scientist kind of
being the overall
preparer of this stuff you're going to
spend 80 percent of your data
preparation
data exploration
that's the fun part this is where you're
exploring things and it is
maybe 10 to 15 percent of what you do
with the data you spend with the data
exploration it is probably
the most important step because this is
where you got to start asking questions
if you ask your questions wrong you're
going to get some wrong information
if you're working with a company and
they want to know the marketing values
then you really got to focus on hey how
do we generate money for this company or
fraud how do we lower the fraud rate
while still generating a profit
four data modeling this is where we
start actually getting into the data
code uh which model to use
that predicts what's going to happen
and then result interpretation we want
to be able to interpret those results
you usually see that in your matplot
library where you create nice beautiful
images so it shows up on their dashboard
for the marketing
manager or for the ceo so they can take
a quick look and say hey i can see
what's going on there you want to reduce
it to something they can easily read
they don't want to hear the scientific
terms they want to see something they
can use
and we'll talk about that a little bit
more when we start looking at some of
this in a demo
since this is data analysis with python
we've got to ask the question why python
for data analytics i mean there's c plus
plus there's java there's dot net from
microsoft why do people go to python for
it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple syntax
you don't have a very high type set like
you do in java and other coding so it
allows you to kind of
be a little lazy in your programming
that doesn't mean that it can't be set
that way and that you don't have to be
careful it just means you can spin up a
code much quicker in python the same
amount of code to do something in python
a lot of times is one two or three or
four lines
where when i did the same thing say in
java i found myself with 10 12 13 20
lines depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible
so there's our flexibility because you
can do a lot with it and you can easily
scale it up you can go from something on
your machine
to using uh pi spark under the spark
environment and spread that across
hundreds if not thousands of servers
across terabytes of data or petabytes of
data so it's very scalable
there's a huge collection of libraries
this one's always interesting because
java has a huge collection of libraries
c has a huge collection of libraries dot
net does and they're always in
competition to get those libraries out
scala for your spark
all those have huge collections of
libraries this is always changing
but because python is open source you
almost always have easy to access
libraries that anybody can use you don't
have to go check your licensing and have
special licensing like you do in some
packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for people to read
and community support because python is
open source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics and we have
python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics
and the big five players are numpy
pandas matplot library scipy which is
going to be in the background so we're
not going to talk too much about the
scientific formulas inside pi in scikit
so numpy supports n-dimensional arrays
provides numerical computing tools
useful for linear algebra and fourier
transform
and you can think of this as just a grid
of numbers
and you can even have a grid inside a
grid
or data it's not even numbers because
you can also put words and characters
and just about anything into that array
but you can think of a grid and then you
can have a grid inside a grid and you
end up with a nice three-dimensional
array
if you want to talk three-dimensional
array you can think of images you have
your three channels of color four if you
have an alpha and then you have your xy
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine watching a
movie well now you have your movie clips
and they each have their x number of
frames and each of those frames have
x number of x y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your three dimensions for the colors so
numpy is just a great way to work with
in-dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas
useful for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame
and if you're working with big data and
you're working in spark or any of the
other major packages out there you
realize that the data frame is very
central to a lot of that and you can
look at it as a excel spreadsheet you
have your columns you have your rows or
indexes and
you can do all kinds of different
manipulations of the data within
including filling in missing data which
is a big thing when you're dealing with
large
pools or
lakes of data where they might be
collected differently from different
locations
and matplot library
we did kick over the sci pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations which
usually runs in the background of the
for of numpy and pandas although you do
use them they're useful for a lot of
other things in there but the matte plot
library that's the final part that's
what you want to show people and this is
your plotting library in python several
toolkits extend matplot library
functionality
there's like a hundred different
toolkits to extend matplot library which
range from how to properly display star
constellations from astronomy there's a
very specific one built just for that
all the way to some uh very generic ones
we'll actually add seaborne in when we
do the labs in a minute several toolkits
extend map plot library functionality
and it creates interactive visualization
so there's all kinds of cool things you
can do as far as just displaying graphs
and there's even some that you can
create interactive graphs we won't do
the interactive graphs but you'll see
you'll get a pretty good grasp of some
of the different things you can do in
matplot library
now let's look at the companies using
data analytics on a daily basis
so we have the e-commerce giant amazon
then we have accenture followed by the
american healthcare service organization
cigna
then we have the american supplier of
health information technology solutions
services devices and hardware cerner
followed by target and antivirus company
mccafe
next
we have rapido which is an indian bike
rental company based in bangalore
after that we have flipkart
and the world's largest retail company
walmart
with that
let's understand a case study from
walmart and how it uses data analytics
to grow its business and serve its
customers better
walmart is an american multinational
retail company
that has over 11 500 stores in 27
countries worldwide and it has
e-commerce websites in 10 different
countries
it has more than 5900 retail units
operating outside the united states with
55 banners in 26 countries with more
than 7 lakh associates serving more than
100 million customers every week
it has over 2.2 million employees around
the world
and 1.5 million employees in the united
states alone
walmart's e-commerce branch alone
employs more than 3 000 technologies
from silicon valley to india england and
south america
more than 240 million customers shop at
walmart each week online and at its
banner stores
walmart.com sees up to 100 million
unique visitors a month according to
comscore and is growing every year
walmart collects over 2.5 petabytes of
data from 1 million customers every hour
that's really huge
to make sense of all this information
walmart has created data cafe a
state-of-the-art analytics hub located
within its bantonville arkansas
headquarters
here over 200 streams of internal and
external data including 40 petabytes of
recent transactional data can be modeled
manipulated and visualized
teams from any part of the business are
invited to bring their problems to the
analytics exports and then see a
solution appear before the rise on the
nerve center's touch screen smart boards
walmart also constantly analyzes over
100 million keywords to know what people
near each store are saying on social
media to understand the customer
behavior on what they like and dislike
walmart uses modern tools and
technologies to derive business insights
and improve customer satisfaction some
of these tools include python sas nosql
databases such as cacendra and hadoop
now using all these technologies and
data analysis techniques walmart can
better manage its supply chain optimize
product assortment personalize the
shopping experience give relevant
product recommendations and finally
optimize and analyze transportation
lanes and routes for its fleet of trucks
so let's start with what is numpy numpy
is the core library for scientific and
numerical computing in python it
provides high performance
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays and i'll go a
step further and say there are so many
other modules in python built on numpy
so the fundamentals of numpy are so
important to latch onto for the python
so you can understand the other modules
and what they're doing numbies main
object is a multi-dimensional array it's
a table of elements usually numbers all
of the same type indexed by a tuple of
position integers in numpy dimensions
are called axes
take a one-dimensional array or we have
remember dimensions are also called axes
you can say this is the first axis
zero one two three four five and you can
see down here it has a shape of six why
because there's six different elements
in it in the one dimension array and
they usually denote that as six comma
with an empty node on there and then we
have a two dimensional array where you
can see zero one two three four five six
seven and in here we have two axes or
two dimensions and the shape is two four
so if you were looking at this as a
matrix or in other mathematical
functions you can see there's all kinds
of importance on shape we're not going
to cover shape today but we will cover
that in part two did you know that
numpy's array class is called nd array
for numpy data array
now we're going to take a detour here
because we're working in python and two
of my favorite tools in python is the
jupiter notebook and then i like to use
that sitting on top of anaconda and if
you flip over to jupiter.org that's
j-u-p-y-t
you can go in here you can install it
off of here if you don't want to use the
anaconda notebook but this is the
jupiter setup the documentation on the
jupiter jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
it's portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run in ipython or
iron python and you can create all kinds
of different environments in there which
i'll show you in just a minute i myself
like to use anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com
if you install anaconda it will install
the jupyter notebook with the anaconda
separate and you can install jupyter
notebook and it'll run completely
separate from anaconda's jupyter
notebook and you can see here i've now
opened up my anaconda navigator what i
like about the navigator and this is a
fresh install on a new computer which is
always nice i can launch my jupiter
notebook from in here i can bring other
tools so the anaconda does a lot more
and under environments i only have the
one environment and i can open up the
terminal specific to this environment
this one happens to have python37 in it
the most current version as of this
tutorial and you open the terminal if
you're gonna do your pip installs and
stuff like that for different modules
you can also create different
environments in here so maybe you need a
python36 python35 you can see we're
having a nice framework like anaconda
really helps so you don't have to ch
track that on your own in the jupyter
notebook in your different jupiter
notebook setups we'll go ahead and
launch this jupyter notebook and then
i've set my browser window for a default
of chrome so it's going to open up in
chrome and you can see here this opens
up a folder on my computer we have a
couple different options on here
remember i set the environment up as
python 3.7 you would install any
additional modules that aren't already
installed in your python on this and it
keeps them separate so you do have to
for each environment install the
separate modules so they match the
environment on there and in here we have
a couple things we can look up what's
running
you have your different clusters again
this is i just installed this on a new
machine so i just have the one a couple
things in here that were run on here
recently and what we go on here is we
then have on the upper right new and
from the pull down menu you'll see
python3
and this will open up a new window
and now we're in jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is let's go hello
world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do is you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these where you have a equals
hello world b equals goodbye world and
you put a b a and return b it'll only
run the last one but you can see here if
you put the variable down here it will
show you what's in that variable
and that has to do with the jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupiter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit
so back to our numpy numpy array versus
python list python list being the basic
list in your python why should we use
numpy array when we have python list
well first it's fast the numpy array has
been optimized over years and years by
multiple programmers and it's usually
very quick compared to the basic python
list setup it's convenient so it has a
lot of functionality in there there's
not in the basic python list and it also
uses less memory so it's optimized both
for speed and memory use
and let's go ahead and jump into our
jupiter notebook since we're coding best
way to learn coding is to code just like
the best way to learn how to write is
right and the best way to learn how to
cook is cook so let's do some coding
here today
and just like any modules we have to
import numpy we almost always import it
as np that is such a standard so you'll
see that very commonly we can just run
that and now we have access to our numpy
module inside our python and then the
most common thing of course is to go
ahead and create a number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array let's do one two three to
make it simple and then i'm just going
to type in a and we'll run this
and so you can see down here the output
is an array of one two three
and we could also do
print
just a reminder that this is an inline
command so that wouldn't work if you're
using a different editor you can see
that it's array123 but we'll go and
leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook
and just like all your other standard
arrays i can go
a of 0
which is going to be a value of 1. of
course we do a of 1. you go all the way
through this
a of 1 has a value of 2 in it
so whether you're using the numpy array
or the basic python list that's going to
be the same that should all look pretty
familiar and be pretty straightforward
remember the first value is always 0
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like and what we want to
look at is the fact that it's fast
convenient and uses less memory so let's
take a glance at that in code and see
what that actually looks like when we're
writing it in python and what the
differences are
and to do this i'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported
so we'll do b equals oh range of one
yeah one thousand is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
one thousand zero to nine hundred ninety
nine remember it starts at zero and it
stops right at the one thousand without
actually going to the 1000
and let's go ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to a thousand we'll
just throw one in there five it doesn't
matter because it's gonna whatever
integer we put in there's gonna generate
the same value because we're looking at
the size of how how much memory it
stores an integer in
and then we want to have the length of
the b that's how many integers are in
there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this at a line we'll see oops i did
that wrong comma
if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28 000 so that's
the size we're looking at is 28 000 i
believe that's bytes that sounds about
right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy
and we'll go with c equals np
and this is a range
so that's the numpy command to do the
same thing that we were just doing in a
list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
and then once we've created the
c
value of c for np.a range let's go ahead
and print
and we can do that by doing c dot size
times
c dot
item size
when it's very similar we did before we
did get the size of so the c size is the
size of the array and each item size
just reversed
so it's the size of an integer five item
size is going to be the integers and c
size and let's just take a look and see
what that generates
and wow okay we got 4000 versus 28 000.
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go ahead and
take a look at speed let's do um oh
let's do size
we tried this with lower values and it
would happen so fast that the npra kept
coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off so size
and let's create an l1
moles
range of size
and we'll do an l2
i'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on a1
equals
np dot
a range size
and then let's do an a
2 equals np dot a range
we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead and just load these
up now we'll go ahead and run this so
those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start
equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is
and it will do result equals and let's
do
oh let's say we got
an array and we're going to say
let's do some addition here x
plus y
for x comma y
and
and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're gonna multiply
each of the individual things on here l1
l2
there we go so that should add up each
value so l1 plus l2 each value in each
array
then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say
python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops i messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time
minus the start and we'll convert that
to second so we'll go uh because in
milliseconds or times 1 000.
and let's hit the run on there this is
kind of fun because you also get a view
while we're doing this
of some ways to manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bed typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually i have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
go ahead and print the result in here
too
let's do that
we'll run that just so you can see what
the what kind of data we're looking at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what
core because i have this is on an eight
core computer so it depends on what core
it's running on what else is pulling on
the computer at the time and let's go
back up here and do our start time
paste that into here
and this time we're gonna do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is so straightforward
this is a lot of reason people started
using numpy is because i can add the two
arrays together by simply going a1 plus
a2
it makes a lot of sense both looking at
it and it's just very convenient
remember that slide we're looking at
fast convenient and less memory so look
how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see
and i don't know if we don't need to
print the result again so let's just go
ahead and print
the time on here
and we'll borrow this from the top part
because i really am a lazy typer
and this isn't the python list this is
the numpy list or number array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out
and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to 3. that's a huge
difference that's that's like
more than 10 times faster that's like 15
times roughly at a quick glance i'd have
to go do the math to look at it and it's
going to vary a little bit depending on
what's running in the background the
computer obviously so we've looked at
this and if we go back here we found out
it's much faster
yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
while we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
these are always nice to see i mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up google is
your friend
we did this with the most basic numpy
dot array or np.array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do pairs
one comma two
and then let's do three comma four and
if we're gonna do that let's do five
comma six
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this
and run this i can go ahead and do our a
down here so it's in line and i'll print
that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a and if you look at that we
have three different objects each with
two values in them and hopefully you're
starting to think well how many
dimensions or indexes is that and you'll
see three by two so let's go ahead and
take a look and let's go how about a dot
in dimensions speaking of which
we'll run that and we have two
dimensions for each object
and then we can do the item size so a
dot
we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we
wanted to multiply item size times the
actual size of the object so the memory
is being used versus the item size
and we should see
four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from
one format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally i don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions i'm always
looking up and this is nice you can
automate it so you might be converting
something you might need to know how
many dimensions are going into the
next machine learning package so that
you can automatically just have it send
that information over
so we looked at a shape let's go and
create a slightly different array in p
dot array let's go ahead and just do as
our original
setup here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do d type
equals in this case let's do
np
float
64. and so what we've done is converting
all of these into a float and we type in
a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values one dot zero there's no actual
zero in there just here's the one dot or
the one period two three period four
period five period six period
and this again data science i don't know
how many times i've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
that's going to work correctly in the
model i'm using
so very common features to be aware of
and to be able to get around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float 64.
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64.
and it should be the same three comma
two so it all matches
so we've gone through and remember if
you really if this is all brand new to
you
according to the cambridge study at the
cambridge university if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it
163 times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we did manage to repeat it
at least twice here if not a little bit
more
and let's go ahead and take this we're
going to look at one more setup on here
and let me just take this last statement
here on the converting our properties of
our data
and instead of float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go and print
that out
and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus zero dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types
better to go to the original web page
but pull up a bunch of these you can see
there's a whole list of different numpy
data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128
complex number represented by 264-bit
floats real and imaginary components
one option on there float16 float32
float shorthand for float64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic addition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we want item size
and there's also
the
shape probably one of the more used i
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
dot
zeros
and we're gonna do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if i do np.0s
i create a numpy array of zeros
this is really important i was building
my own neural network and i needed to
create an array where i initialized the
weights and i want them all to be the
same weight in this case i wanted them
to start off as zero for the particular
project i was working on and there's
other options like you can do numpy ones
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that
and you can see i've created a an array
of numpy ones in this case it comes out
as a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
python and do l range five
and we'll print the l so as our list and
if i run that
it doesn't create the range until after
the fact until you actually execute it
that's an upgrade in python python27
actually created the array zero one two
three four this one actually creates the
script and then once it's used it then
actually generates the array
and if we do that in numpy a range
remember that from before
and if we do a numpy a range 5
and let's do uh l equals
or we can just leave it as numpy that's
fine there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array zero one two three four for the
value the numpy arrange a range five
generates the actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic
setup
and we're going to concatenation
do a concatenation out example
there we go we're gonna do strings let's
take a look at uh strings what's going
on with there
and let's do
oh let's see print
let's do an np
character something new here
and we're going to add
and then here's our brackets for what
we're going to add
oh and let's say
let's do
hello
comma hi
and in the brackets on there let's
create another one
and this one's going to be
abc
and we'll do
xyz so we're just creating some randomly
making some up on here and then we'll go
ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here
and of course make sure all your
brackets are open and closed correctly
and then
you can see in here when we concatenate
the example in numpy
it takes the two different arrays that
we set up in there and it combines the
hello with the abc and the high with xyz
and if we can also do something like
print
oh let's do
np character dot
multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three and we'll run this one
and run that without the error you'll
see it does hello hello hello so we
multiplied it by three and we can also
let's just take this whole thing here
instead of retyping it
and we can do character
center so instead of multiply let's do
center
and over here
keep our hello going
take the space out of there and let's do
center at 20
and fill
character
equals and we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side
and we keep going um with that we can
also in addition to doing the fill
function we can play with capitalize we
can title we can do lowercase we can do
uppercase we can split split line strip
join these are all the most common ones
and let's go ahead and just look at
those and see what those look like each
one of them
here we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine i would like
to say hello universe and you can see
here we did a capital h with the world
but so we want to capitalize so
capitalize is the first one in the array
so we get hello world on there and we
can also take this
and instead of capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how
are you doing instead of
do you
let's run that
and you can see here because we created
as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have hello world all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that
you get a an array with hello world
lowercase and hello lowercase
and if we're going to do it that way we
can also do it the opposite way there's
also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have
character.upper opposite there
python.data and we'll do python is easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the python and the
scripting is very simple
it's when you put the bigger picture
together and starts building these
puzzles and somebody asks you hey i need
the first letter capitalized unless it's
the title and then we have you start
realizing that this can get really
complicated so numpy just makes it
simple and we like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase python is easy like
shouting in your messenger python is
easy
and then if you're ever processing text
and tokenizing it a lot of times the
first thing you do is we just split the
text and we're just going to run this in
p dot character dot split are you coming
to the party if we do that returns an
array of each of the individual words
are you coming to the party splitting it
by the spaces
and then if we're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines
hello and you'll see here the scoop in
for our new line
and when we run that if you're following
the split part with the words you should
see hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have nina admin anita
and we're going to strip a off of there
let's see what that looks like
and then you end up with nin diminish it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a
more common would be a space in there
but it might also be punctuation or
anything like that that you need to
remove from your letters and words and
if we're going to strip and clean data
we also need to be able to reformat it
or join it together so you see here we
have a character join we'll go ahead and
run this
and it has on the first one it splits
these letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to be have to always
switch around and manipulate depending
on what they're going into and what
you're working with
and finally let's look at one last
character string
we're going to do replace
if you're doing misinformation this is
good pulling news articles replacing
is and what in this case we're just
doing he's a good dancer and we're going
to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and has gotten old
so there we go we covered a lot of the
basics in numpy as far as creating an
array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
when we convert it from a regular
integer into a float value as far as how
much space it takes we saw that that
doubled it item size you have your in
dimensions and probably the most used is
shape and we'll cover more on shape in
part two so make sure you join us on
part two because a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up
we also saw that you can create a
zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into
doing strings and working with strings
and how to concatenate so if you have
two different arrays of strings you can
bring them together we also saw how you
can fill so you can add a nice headline
dash dash dash
we saw about capitalize the first letter
we saw about turning it into a title so
all the first letters are capitalized
doing lowercase on all the letters upper
for all the letters just lower and upper
nice abbreviation we also covered how to
split the character set how to strip it
so if you want to strip all the a's out
from leading aias and ending a's or
spaces you can do that very easily also
how to join the data sets so here's a
character join option for your strings
and finally we did the character replace
now let's go ahead and dive in there
since we're going right into part two
which is getting some coding going under
our belt
and here in our jupiter notebook we can
go under new and create a new folder
python 3.
i think i forgot to do this last time
but we could just do the
control plus plus which in any browser
enlarges the page makes it a lot easier
to see always a nice feature another
beautiful benefit of using jupiter
notebook
and let me go ahead and show you a neat
thing we can do in jupiter this is nice
if you're working with people and you're
doing this as a demo on a large screen
i'm going to do the hashtag or pound
symbol array manipulation kind of a
title that we're working on and then i'm
going to call this cell cell type
markdown as opposed to code and you'll
see it highlights it here and then if i
run it it just turns it into array
manipulation and then we're specifically
going to be working on array
manipulation changing shape to start
with
and we'll go ahead and mark this cell
also a markdown so has a nice little
look there and then it comes up and you
can see it just like i said it just
highlights it and makes it very bold
print just making it easier to read not
a python thing but a jupiter thing
that's good to know about especially if
you're working with the shareholders
since they're investing money in you of
course the first thing we do is import
we're going to import numpy
as in p that should be standard by now
by now you you start a python program
you're doing some data science numpy is
just something you bring in there and
let's go ahead and create our array and
we're going to do that as the np
dot a range remember that's a zero well
we're going to do zero to nine
and then we'll print
a little title on the original array
we'll just print that array a remember
from the first lesson so we have our
array which is 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
and let's add a print space in between
let's create a second array b but we
want this to reshape array a and what
does that mean
and the command is simply reshape and
then we have nine items in here and this
is so important right now so be very
aware if i did some weird numbers in
here it's not gonna work
and we want multiples of nine we know
that three times three is nine
so we're going to reshape
our a array by three by three and then
we're going to print well let's give it
a title
oops i have too many brackets in there
modified array and then let's go ahead
and print
our b and let's see what that looks like
and as we come down here you can see
we've taken this and it's gone from
zero one two three four five six seven
eight to an array
of arrays and we have zero one two three
four five six seven eight and so we
split this into three by three and you
can guess that if i tried to reshape
this let's just do a five by three
which is 15
that's going to give me an error so it's
not going to work you're not going to
reshape something unless the shape all
the the data in there matches correctly
so we can take this nine this flat nine
and they call it flex it's just a single
array and we can reshape it into a three
by three array and first you might think
matrixes which this is used for that
definitely i use it a lot in graphing
because they'll come in that i have an
array that's x y comma x y one y one
comma x two y two and so the shape of it
might be 2 by the length of the number
of points
and i need to separate that into
x flat ray and a y flat array you can
see this can be very easy to reshape the
array doing that and we can of course go
back we can do b
do a print
and we'll do b dot
latin remember i said it's called a
flatten array
and if we run that
you'll see it just goes back to the
original one it takes this 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 and flattens it back to a single
array
and then one other feature to be aware
of is if we flatten it one of the
commands we can put in there is order
let me just go ahead and do that order
equals
f strangely enough f
stands for fortran
the whole fortran days i remember
actually studying fortran programming
language
in this case you'll see that it uses the
first like 036
is the order so instead of flattening it
like we had before zero one two three
four five six seven eight it now does
zero three six one four seven two five
eight
and if you go to the numpy array page
you can see here that they have the
flatten and you just open up the numpy
and d array flattened setup to look it
up and they have three different options
they have c
f and a
and it's whether to flatten in c which
was based on how the c code works for
flattening originally worked which is
row major
fortran which is column major or
preserve the column fortran ordering
from a so whatever it was in the default
is the
c version so the default that you saw
you could put orders equal c and it'd
have the same effect as we saw there
before you could even do order equals a
that would also have the same effect
because that's the default so really the
only other thing you really need to
change on here is to change it to c if
you need it
and you can see right here or f i mean
not c the only thing you really want to
change it to is to your f for the
fortran order which then does it by
column versus by row and let's look at
here we go
reshape
so let's create a range of 12.
and let's reshape it
i will do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy i forgot the np
there
in p dot arrange
and we can type in just a for print or
you can do full print a and of course in
jupyter notebook even have a little
extra print at the beginning we run this
we'll see we create a nice array of zero
one two it's reshaped it so we have
four rows and three columns or you could
call that three columns and four rows
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven
but this one is so important we'll do np
transpose a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if i get all the s's in
there don't leave an s out and you'll
see here we've taken our array if you
remember correctly we had 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 eleven
and we've swapped it so we've gone from
a three by four or a four by three to a
three by four
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge number of rows and the
data all comes in like let's say this is
your features in row one your features
in row two
and this is x y z well when you go to
plot it you send it all of x in one
array all the y and i'm entering all z
in another array
and so it's really important that we can
transpose this rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing i can
highlight it and do brackets around it
and if you remember correctly
because we're in jupiter it doesn't
matter where we do the print or not
it'll automatically print it for us and
you see if i hit the run button it comes
up at the same exact thing
and let's play with the reshape and you
know let's zoom this up a little bit
here
make that even bigger so you can really
see what's going on and let's play with
the reshape just a little bit more we'll
do b equals
np dot a range let's do 8
and reshape
we'll do 2 comma 4.
let's go ahead and print b
and then run that
and you'll see we have now the two rows
this is a bit more like so we have four
maybe two rows of four things so this
might be all of our x components and our
y components so we can switch it back
and forth real easy important to know
here whether we do 2 comma 4 or in the
case of 4 comma 3
this has 12 elements and so however you
split it up it's got to equal 12.
so 4 times 3 equals 12 that's pretty
straight forward same thing down here
2 times 4 equals 8. if i change this and
let's say i do 2 comma 3 let's just run
that in
and you'll find we get an error because
you can't split eight up into two rows
by three
you have to pick something that it can
split up and arrange it in so let's go
ahead and run that and just for fun
let's go um
reshape our b again if i can type
reshape our b again and what else goes
into eight well we could do
two by two by two
so we can take this out to three
different dimensions
and then of course if we um because this
is going to come out you you as a
variable we can just go ahead and run it
and it'll print it we can also do a
print statement on there just like we
did before and you'll see we have two
different groups of two variables of two
different dimensions so two by 2 by 2.
and let's go ahead and assign this to a
variable c equals b reshape
and let's do something a little
different
let's roll the axes roll
axes
and we'll take our c
do 2 comma 1
and if we go ahead and run this it's
going to print that out whoops
hit a wrong button there let's do that
one again and you roll the axis and you
can see that we now have a set of 0 1 2
3 4 six seven we now have the zero two
one three four six five seven
so what's going on here we're taking and
we're rolling the numbers around and
let's just simplify this we'll just do
it with c comma one and run that and so
if we roll a single axis you got 0 1
and then it rolled the 4 5
up and then we have 2 3 6 7. and if we
do 2
let me see what happens there this is
one of those things you really have to
play with and start filling what it's
doing
we've now taken 0 2
4 6 1 3 5 7 so you can see we've now
rolled by two digits instead of rolling
the one set up we now rolled two digits
up there and so if we go back and we do
the one
so we've rolled it up zero one four five
and then we're gonna take the two in
there and we've rolled the zero one two
three four five and six seven
so we start rolling these things around
on here there's a lot of different
things you can do on this
but it's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your numpy
and finally let's go ahead and swap
axes
we'll do c
and let's just go ahead and run that
it's going to give me an error on there
that's because it requires multiple
arguments left out the arguments so now
we can swap and we get the zero two one
three four six five seven so you can see
everything's been swapped around so next
thing we want to go over is we want to
go over numpy
arithmetic operations
how can we take these and use these let
me just go ahead and put this cell as a
markdown there we go we'll run that so
it has a nice thing all right nice title
on there that's always helpful
and let's start by creating two arrays
we'll do uh a as an ep np
range a range nine and let's reshape
this
three by three so by now you should be
saying this reshape stuff and this
should all look pretty familiar we have
a zero one two three four five six seven
eight on there and let's create a second
one b
and this time instead of doing a range
let's do n p array we'll just create a
straight up array
and we'll do an array of three objects
so it's going to be
three by one and if we go ahead and
print a b out let me run that this is
actually pretty common to have something
like this where you have a three by
whatever it is in a three by three array
when you're doing your math you kind of
have that kind of setup on there
and what we can do is we can go
mp.add
a b
don't forget we can always put a print
statement on there
so if we add it you'll see that it just
comes in there and it goes okay we're
adding 10 to everything and we could
actually do something more i'll make it
more interesting 11 10 11 12. so let's
change b's now 10 11 12 and let's run
that
and you can see that we have
10 and then you had 1 plus 11 is 12
2 plus 12 is 14
13 so 10 plus 3 is 13 11 plus 4 is 15
and 12 plus 5 is 17 and so on
we'll put this back since that's how the
original setup was let's do 10 by 10 by
10 and run that and run that and get the
original answer and if you're going to
add them together we need to go ahead
and subtract
a b and we run that
we get minus 10 minus 9 minus 8 just
like you would expect
so we have our subtraction 0 minus 10 is
minus 10 and so on and if you're going
to add and subtract you can guess what
the next one is we're going to multiply
and we'll multiply
a b
and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply 10 times 0 we got 0 10
times 10 is 10 and so on
and finally if you're going to multiply
what's the last one we got is divide
what happens we do divide a by b
and we run this
and we're going to get 0 and this is
0 divided by 10 is 0. 1 divided by 10 is
0.1 2 divided by 10 is 0.2 and so on and
so on so the math is pretty
straightforward it just makes it very
easy to do the whole setup and again if
we went this and let's say i'll just
change this up here instead of 10
we do a hundred
and
make this a thousand there we go
if we run that and then we do the add
you can see we got 10
plus 100 plus a thousand
same thing with the subtract
same thing with the multiply
and then you can also see the same thing
here with the divide so a lot of control
there with your array and your math
again let's set this back to 10 oops
it's right up here wrong section
there we go 10. we'll just go ahead and
run these
and get back to where we were
and this brings us to our next section
which is slicing and let's put in our
just make this a cell
cell type markdown and when we run that
of course it gives us a nice looking
slicing there and slicing means we're
just going to take sections of the array
so let's create an array in p a range
let's just do
20.
and if you remember if we do a
we have a 0 to 19.
and then we can do a and remember we can
always print these this can always be
put in a print but because i'm in
jupiter if you're doing a demo in
jupiter that is it's just so great that
you have all these controls on here so
we can slice four on and this should
look familiar because this is the same
as a python and a lot of other different
scripting languages if we do four go
zero 1 2
3 that's the first four in the thing and
the skip sum and starts with this one
the first four skip then from there on
you can also do the opposite
and go till the fourth one if we run
that we get 0 1 2 3 quite the opposite
on there we can do a single line up so
we can pick object number 5 on the list
run that and 5 happens to be 5 because
that's the order they're in
and then this one's interesting so i can
do s equals slice
and let's create a slice here
and let's do two comma nine comma
yeah let's leave it two on there so
we'll create an s slice on here and then
if we take our array and we do array of
s we're taking our slice in there and
let's go ahead and run that
and let's take a look and see what it
generated here first off we started with
two so we have two at the beginning
we're going to end at nine which happens
to be eight so it stops before the nine
remember when we're doing arrays in
python and then we step two so two four
six eight we could do this as three let
me run that and you can see how the
changes to five eight
and we could do this as let's leave this
at 3 and if we change this to 10
oops let's make it 12. there we go
when we run that we have 2 5 8 11. so
that's pretty straightforward it's a
very nice feature to have on here we can
slice it
and take different parts of the series
right out of the middle so now that
we've accessed the different pieces of
our array
let's get into iterating iteration and
this is interesting because
my sister who runs a college data
science
division the first question she asks
is
how do you go through data and she's
asking can you do you know how to
iterate through data do you know how to
do a basic for loop you know how to go
through each piece of the data and in
numpy they have some cool controls for
that this one's a markdown there we go
and run it
and it's called the nd iter i'm not sure
what the nd stands for but ndeiter for
iterator
so before we do that though let's create
an array or something we can actually
iterate through
we'll call it a equals np
a range
let's do something a little funny here
or funky
and we'll do 0 45
5. i'm not sure
why the guys in the back picked this
particular one it's kind of a fun one
and if i run that we do this you can see
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. that's
what this array looks like
and that's just from our slice you could
this is just a slice that's all that is
is we created a slice of 0 45 0 to 45
step 5. and so we can do with this we
can also do a equals the shape
let's go ahead and take and reshape this
and since there's nine variables in
there we'll do a reshape it three by
three so if we run that oops missed
something there that is the a
that really helps
so if we do the a reshape
and we'll go ahead and print that out
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
and then we simply do 4 x in
our numpy nd enter
of a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
x
and let's see what happens here when we
run through this and we print each one
of those
it goes all the way through the whole
array so it's the same thing we just saw
before we got 0 5 10
15 20 25 30 35 40. so it prints out each
object in the array so you can go
through and view each one of these
and certainly if you remember you could
also flatten the array and just do for
a and that also and get the same result
there's a lot of ways to do this but
this is the proper way with the nd
iterator because it'll
minimize the amount of resources needed
to go through each of the different
objects in the numpy array
and hopefully you asked this question i
just did that
and the question is how can i change
this instead of doing each object so
first of all let's go ahead and take my
cell type and we mark that down and run
it
and so we're going to work on iteration
order c style and f style remember c
because it came from the c programming
and f because it came from the old
fortran programming so let's give us a
reminder i will do a print a
and we'll do 4 x in
np
iterate
a
but we also want to do this in a
specific order and you know what i'm a
really lazy typer so let's go back up
here
this is the nd iterator i knew it was
missing the nd part of a
let's do order
equals
c
we'll print x on there and let's do that
again and this time order
order equals
f
there we go order equals f let's go
ahead and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing you're going to notice our
original array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
when we do order c that's the default
0 5 10 15 20 and so on and then when you
come down here
you'll see f order f is 0 15 30. so it
takes the first digit of each on the
subarrays or the second dimension and
then it goes into the second one 5 20 35
10 25 40. so slightly different order
for iterating through it if you need to
do that so we've covered reshaping we
covered math we've covered iteration
we've covered a number of things the
next section we want to go ahead and go
over
it's going to be joining arrays so we
need to bring them together let me go
ahead and take the cell and make it a
markdown
cell type markdown there we go and run
that so let's work on joining arrays so
we can bring them together and what
different options we have
and let's do uh we'll do an n p array
one two
comma three four
we'll go ahead and print
let's do
oops
first
these rays aren't that big so let's just
go ahead and keep it all on one line a
so if we run this first array one two
three four oops i forgot that it
automatically wraps it when you do it
this way so we'll go ahead and keep it
separate
and print
a there we go
and let's go ahead and do a b
and we'll do five six seven eight and
notice i'm keeping the same shape on
these two arrays
depending on what you're doing those
shapes have to match
and let's go ahead and print
second array
do a print
b
i'll go ahead and run that oops
missed something up there let me fix
that real quick
when i was reformatting it to go on
separate lines i messed that up there we
go run all right so we have first array
one two three four second array five six
seven eight
and we'll put a carriage return on there
and the keyword we use is um concatenate
and if you're familiar with linux it
usually means you're adding it to the
end
on there and we're going to do what they
call a long axis zero so we have
concatenate a b along axis zero let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like
and so we have one two three four five
six seven eight so now we have an array
that is four by two has a nice shape of
four by two one here
and if we're going to do it along the
axis zero
you should guess what the next one is
we're going to do it along the one axis
and let's see how those differ from each
other let's just go ahead and run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axis equals one so we have our
concatenate we have a b and then axis
one remember a couple things one these
are the same shape so we have a two by
two
same dimensions going in there you're
going to get an error if you're
concatenating and they're not if you
have something that instead of one two
is one two three four five six with a
five six seven eight they'll give you an
error on there in fact let's take a look
and see what happens when we do that let
me just take this
one two three
three four five and let's run that and
if we come down here oh we got there it
says all the input ray dimensions except
for the concatenation axes m
must match exactly
so it'll let you know if you mess up
that's always a good thing let's go
ahead and take this back here and let's
go ahead and run that
and so we have our zero axes which is
one two three four five six seven eight
and we bring them together
and you'll see a very different set up
here when we do it along the axis one
we end up with instead of
four by two we end up with a two by four
one two five six three four seven eight
and this is changing which axes we're
gonna go ahead and concatenate on what i
find is when you're talking about the
concatenate or the joining arrays
you really got to play with these for a
while to make sure you understand what
you mean by the axes it looks very
intuitive when you're looking at it
actually 0
one two three four five six seven eight
axes one is then splitting in a
different way one two five six three
four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does
so if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and look at splitting the array
and do that under markdown and run it
there we go so you have a nice little
title there
and we'll go ahead and create an array
of nine
let's do np split
we'll do a and we're going to split it
by three
let's just see what that looks like so
if we split it we get an array zero one
two three four five we get three
separate arrays on here and remember
we're looking at let me just print a up
here
so we're looking at zero one two three
four five six seven eight and then we
can split it into three separate arrays
and let's take this we're gonna do this
right down here just move the a split
down here instead of the three let's do
four comma five and put that in brackets
and so we do it this way we have zero
one two three
four five six seven eight and that's
kind of interesting i wasn't sure what
to expect on that but we get when you
split it a by four comma five you get a
totally different setup on here as far
as the way it split the array
and to understand how this works
i'm going to change the five to a seven
and this will visually make this a
little bit more clear
so we had four and five it went zero one
two three four five six seven eight and
you see the markers four and five when
we do four and seven i get zero one two
three four five six
seven eight
and so what you're looking at here is
the first markers this is going to go to
four so there's our first split at the
four the marker of four and then the
second split is going to be at position
seven and this is the same thing here
four position five that's why we're
splitting it in those two sections we
could also do it seventh let's just see
what that looks like run
and you can see i now have zero one two
three four five six seven eight
so we can split in all kinds of
different ways and create a different
set of
multiple arrays on here and split it all
kinds of different ways
and before we get into the graphs and
other
miscellaneous stuff
let's go ahead and look at resizing the
array i'm going to take the cell and set
the cells a mark down and run it
give us a nice title there and we'll do
an array uh an input array of one two
three and four five six here i'm just
gonna just print
let's go print
a dot
shape and we'll go ahead and run that
whoops hit a wrong button there
hit the comma instead of the dot so we
have a shape of 2 comma 3 here
and this is important to note because we
start resizing it it's going to mess
with different aspects of the shape
and so we'll go ahead and do a print
scoop in for a blank line there we go
let's do b equals
np dot resize
we're gonna resize a
and let's resize it with
three by two
and then we'll just go ahead and
print b
and print
b period shape not a comma
i'll run that
oops forgot the quotation marks around
the end we'll go ahead and run that and
let's just see what that looks like so
we have
one two three four five six our original
array with a shape of two three
and then we want to go ahead and resize
it by three two and we end up with one
two three four 5 6 and we end up with a
shape of 3 2. that shouldn't be too much
of a surprise
you know we got 6 elements in there we
can resize it by 2 3 was the original
one and then we're actually just
reshaping is how that kind of comes out
as when you resize it like that
but what happens if we do something a
little different
and let's go ahead and just take this
whole thing and copy it down here so you
can see what that looks like
and instead of doing 3 2 remember last
time i did the
to reshape it
i messed with the numbers and it gave me
an error
when you resize it you don't have to
match the numbers they don't have to be
the same dimensions so we instead of
going from a 2 3 to a 3 2 we can resize
it to a 3 3. so let's take a look and
see how it handles that and we come down
here to 3 3
we end up with 1 2 3 4 5 6 and it
repeats 1 2 3.
so it actually takes the data and just
adds a whole other block in there based
on the original data and repeating it
all right now at this point you know
we've been looking at tons of numbers
and moving stuff around
we want to go ahead and do is get a
little visual here because that
certainly you can picture all the
different
numbers on there but let's look at
histogram let's put this into a
histogram let me go ahead and run that
and to do that we're going to use the
matte plot library so from matplot
library we're going to import pi plot as
plt
that's usually the notation you see for
pi plot
so if you ever see plt in a code it's
probably pi plot in the matplot library
and then the guys in the back did a nice
job and gals too guys and gals back
there
our team over at simply learn put
together a nice array for me 20 87 4 40
with a bunch of numbers that way we had
something to play with
and we want to do is we wanted to plot
the histogram now remember a histogram
says how many times
different numbers come in and then we're
going to put them in bins and we have
been 0 to 20 to 40 to 60 to 80 to 100.
you might in here with the matplot
library they call them bins you might
heard the term buckets or they put them
in buckets that's a really common term
then we want to give it a title so the
way it works is you do your plt.hist for
histogram your plt title and your plt
show
and we're doing just a single array in
here in the numpy array of a and let's
go ahead and run this piece of code
taking a moment to come out there says
figure size so it's generating the graph
and you can see we have let's just take
a look at this and go down a size there
we go okay so now we can see we're
taking a look at here
so between 0 and 20
we have three values so we have a 20
here we have a 4 and a 11 and a 15
0 1 2 3 it's actually four values but
they start at zeros remember we always
count from zero up
and from 20 to 40 we got 20 this is 1 42
three
four
five six
and so you can see in the histogram it
shows that the most common numbers
coming up
is going to be between the 40 and 60
range least common between the 80 and
100 this looks like a age demographics
that's what this looks like to me and
you can see where they would have put it
in the buckets of different age groups
which would be a nice way of looking at
this
histograms are so important so powerful
when you're doing
demos and explaining your data so being
able to quickly put a histogram up that
shows
what's common and how it's trending is
really important
and using that with a numpy
is really easy
and you know what let's take the same
data and i want to show you why we do
bins or why we have buckets of data i'm
used to calling it buckets why we have
bins let's do it instead of by 20 let's
do it by tens and see what happens
and what happens when you do it by tens
is you miss out on the you can see a
nice curve here on the first one
and on the second one it looks like a
ladder going up and a plummet a ladder
going up and a plummet and a ladder
going down
so the first would be more indicative of
an age group and the second one would be
what you would get if you divide it
incorrectly you wouldn't see the natural
trend of
i don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat hopefully not
because i'm in 50 so i'm right in the
middle there that which means i get a
ton of food compared to everybody else
but it's some kind of democrat maybe
it's mental maybe it's knowledge because
we we hit a certain point and we start
losing our marbles start leaking out or
something so you start off knowing
something and then as you get older you
grow more but you see here we lose that
you lose that continuity in the thing if
you split the histogram into too many
bins or too many buckets
and if you actually plotted this by the
individual numbers it would just be a
bunch of dots
on the graph it wouldn't mean a whole
lot
and we've looked at graphs there are
terms that are a ton of useful functions
in numpy
i'm sure there's even new ones that are
going to be in here but let's just cover
some important ones you really need to
know about if you're using the numpy
framework
one of them is line space function this
is generating data so we have a line
space we have 1 3 10 and when we do that
we end up with
ten numbers so if you count them there's
ten numbers they're between one and
three and they're evenly spaced we get
one one point two two two but these are
all there's a total of ten here and it's
right between the one and three range
that could be there's a lot of uses for
that but they're probably more obscure
than a lot of the other common numpy
arrays set up
a real common one is to do summation so
we'll do summation
where you do in this case we create a
numpy array of one of um
two different arrays one two three or
two different dimensions one two three
three four five
and we're going to sum them up under
axes zero which is your columns
and if you remember correctly columns is
the one plus three two plus four three
plus five so we have three columns and
if we change this we'll just flip this
to one
we get two numbers so we get one two
three all added together which equals
six and three plus four plus five which
equals 12. we'll set this back to zero
there we go since it was just we're
looking to actually zero
and these probably could have been some
of these communities our math section
square root and standard deviation two
very important
tools we use throughout the machine
learning process
in data science
and simply we take the np array we have
again the one two three four five six
three four five i don't know why i need
to keep recreating it probably could
just kept it but we can take the square
root of a so it goes through and it
takes the square root of all the
different terms in a
and we can also take the standard
deviation how much they deviate in value
on there
and there's a rabble function we can run
that
and in p array is x we're going to do x
equals say we change it from a to x
x equals
ravel and this sets it up as columns so
we have one two three four five this is
all columns on here very similar to the
flattened function
so they kind of look almost identical
but we also the option of doing a ravel
by column
and then another one is log so you can
do mathematical log on your array in
this case we have 1 2 3
and we'll find the
log base 10 for each of those three
numbers
there's a couple of them they don't you
can't just do any number here after log
but there is also log base 2.
log base 10 is pretty commonly used on
here
run that there we go
before we go let's have a little fun
let's do a little practice session here
on some more challenging questions so
you start to think how this stuff fits
together right now we just looked at all
the basics and all the basic tools you
have
so let's do some numpy practice examples
and let's start by figuring out how do
you plot say a sine wave in numpy how
what would that look like and so in this
project we wouldn't have to do this
because i've already run these but we'd
want to go ahead and import our numpy as
np and import our matplot library piplot
as plt so we get our tools going here
and then we'll break it into two
sections because we need our x y
coordinates in here
so first off let's create our x
coordinates
and our x coordinates we're going to set
to an a range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing
sine and cosine it's going to be between
0 and 0.1
and then we use our np and we actually
can look up numpy stores pi so you have
the option just pulling pi in there
directly from numpy it has a few other
variables that it stores in there that
you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here and let's go ahead and run this
and just out of curiosity let's see what
x looks like i always like to do that so
we have point one point two point three
point four so we're going uh zero to
in this case nine point four three times
number pi
pi is like three point something
something something so that makes sense
it should be about nine and we're doing
intervals of 0.1 so we create a nice
range of data and then we need to create
our y variable and so y
is going to simply equal np our numpy
dot sine
of x
and then
once we have our x and y
and if we print let's go and just print
y
see how that will do this let's do this
so it looks print
x print y
so we basically have two arrays of data
so we have like our x-axis and our
y-axis going on there
and this is simply a plt-dot plot
because we're going to plot the points
and we'll do x comma y
and then we want to actually see the
graph so we'll do plot dot show
and we'll go ahead and run that
and you see we get a nice sine wave and
here's our number zero through nine
and here's our sine value which
oscillates between -1 and 1 like we
expected to
then for the next challenge
let's create a 6x6 two-dimensional array
and let 1 and 0 be placed alternatively
across the diagonals
oh that's a little confusing so let's
think about that we're going to create a
six by six
two dimensional so the shape is six by
six two dimensional array
and let one and zero be placed
alternatively across the diagonals
now if you remember from lesson one we
can fill a whole numpy array with zeros
or ones or whatever so we're going to do
np or create a numpy zeros and we're
gonna do a six by six and we'll go ahead
and make sure it knows it's an integer
even though it's usually the default and
just real quick let's take a look and
see what that looks like so if i run
this you can see i get
six by six grid so six by six zero zero
zero zero zero
now if i understand this correctly when
they say ones and zero placed
alternatively across the diagonals
they want the center diagonal maybe it's
going to stay zero all the way down
and then the next diagonal will be ones
all the way across diagonally and then
the next one zeros the next one ones the
next one zeros and so on hopefully you
can see my mouse lit up there and
highlighting it so let's take a little
piece of code here
and we'll do z
1 colon colon 2 comma colon colon 2
equals 1. and wow that's a mouthful
right there so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that's doing and so
what we're doing is we're saying hey
let's look at in this case row one
there's one and then we're going to go
every other row two so we're going to
skip a row so skip here skip here skip
here so we're going down
this way and we're going every other row
going this way it's hard to highlight
columns
so you can see right here where the that
we're not touching each row like this
row right here is not being touched okay
so we're going to start with row one and
then we're going to skip a row and
another one and so we're going every two
rows and then in every two rows we're
looking at every two
starting with the beginning that's what
this thing is blank means so we're going
to start with the beginning and we're
going to look at all of them but we're
going to skip every two
so starting with row one
we look at all the rows but we do we do
it by two steps so we go one skip one
you know one skip one one skip one one
if you left this out i'd do every one
this would just be ones in fact let's
see what this looks like if i go like
this
and run it
you can see that i guess get ones
so this notation allows us to go down
each row row by row and we're going to
do every other row
set up on there and so if we're going to
start with row 1 we also control z
try that there we go we'll start with
row zero again we're going to go each
row step two so we'll start with row
zero
and we'll go every other row
and this time we'll start with one
column one
and again we go every other one going
down
step that's what that step two is and
skipping every other one we're gonna set
that equal to one so let's see what that
looks like
and you can see here we get our answer
we get zero one 0 0 but it has the ones
going in diagonals
on every other diagonal and 0 on every
other one
a little bit of a brain teaser that one
trying to get that one to work out so
you can see how you can arrange your
rows and here's your step and your
different axis on there
and then the next one is
find the total number and locations of
missing values in the array the first
challenge is to create some missing
numbers so let's create our ray z we're
going to do uh numpy dot random.rand 10
comma 10. and before we do the second
part let me just take the second part
out
and let's just see what that looks like
so let's run that
and there we go so we have a 10 by 10
random array it randomly is picking out
numbers
and
next we want to go ahead and take our
random integer size equals five
and then we're going to do a random
random 10 size equals five
so in the z we're going to select a
number of random spaces here and set
them equal to
null value and let's go ahead and run
that so you can see what that looks like
and if we look at the array
we've created one two
three
four
there should be a fifth one in here my
eyes may be filling me so we've created
a series of out because zero zero to
five zero one two three four so we've
got five there are different null values
on here
and
this is kind of a neat notation to
notice that we can generate
random integers size equals five so this
generates
five by five miniature grid inside of
this to tell it where to put the nands
at so that's kind of a cool little thing
you can do
and then we want to look up and see how
many null values are in there
and this is simply just
np is nan of z
simple
so if it is none then we want to sum it
up so we're going to sum up all of the
different null values on there now let's
do one one more feature in here which is
really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
np arg where np is
nan of z so we're going to create our
own another np array and let's run this
and we'll see here that comes up with
the four indexes
so we did count four of them up there
it tells you where they are one nine two
zero four six five four
and then let's go ahead and run this
again run run there we go this time i
got five that's what get for random
numbers another fun one
that i always like to do it's very
similar because we have np is not z dot
sums we're summing the number of
nands and we can get the indexes and you
can reshape the indexes but you can also
just do we'll do an inds where np is n
of z
and let's just print let's print that
print
inds let's see what that looks like
and it's very similar we have we have
zero one three zero six three eight six
nine three
but i've split it into two different
arrays
so we have our x and our y kind of
coordinates going there and what i can
now do is i can now do z
inds
equals and at this point you can also
instead of getting the sum you can get
the means or the all the numbers and
that kind of thing or the average as it
is so that'd be one thing you could do
and you could pick up the average that's
very common in data science to get the
average and just use that for a value
but we'll go and just set it to zero and
then let's go ahead and print our z and
run that
and you can see we come down here
we have wherever there was a null value
it is now
zero
and you can set this whatever you want
this is another way to replace data or
help clean data
depending on what it is you're doing
so wow we covered a lot of stuff so
quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at array
manipulation changing the shape
how to switch that around we even had
the flattened down there which remember
we have another command lower that's
similar we could change the order by f
remember f stands for fortran very
strange connotation but there's c and f
c is the standard and f switches it to a
different order to be honest i usually
have to look it up because i almost
never use f but when you need it you're
like oh my gosh it was the other order
just do a quick google so we talked
about reshape making sure that the
dimensions are the same you don't want
to have like something that has 12
objects in it and reshape it to
see 11 and 5 because it doesn't work it
doesn't divide into 12. we can transpose
so we can switch them so we can go from
a 4 by 3 to a 3 by 4. oops i did it the
other way around
three by four to four by three
we covered reshaping the array we did
the roll the axes you can do some weird
things with swapping and rolling axes
and transposing the numbers
we dug a little bit into the arithmetic
so we talked about
adding we talked about subtracting
multiplying dividing
and you know at this point it's so
important we just look up the numpy
mathematics and you can see here they
have just about everything your
trigonometry
uh your hyperbolic functions roundings
sums products differences
there are so many all these different
miscellaneous mathematical connotation
so you know google it go to the main
numpy page and look at the different
setups you can do on there
so we covered that
and we did slicing how to break it apart
we did iterating over the array
we covered joining arrays and how to
concatenate remember concatenate just
means add on to it so in this case how
are you adding b onto a is how you read
that from linux you should catch the
concatenate
because that's used regularly there
splitting the array we talked about how
to split the array in different ways so
you can split it in
array of arrays all kinds of different
ways to split the array up how to resize
it and remember resize does not have to
have the same shape but if you resize it
it will take the data and begin at the
beginning and add new rows on if the
size is bigger if it's smaller it
truncates it it just cuts the end off
we looked at how to do a histogram and
how to plot that
uh we mentioned
buckets or bins as they call them in pie
plot and then we covered a lot of other
useful functions in numpy talked about
the line space set up for doing
numbers in a series
how to sum the axes up again that's part
of the mathematical formulas there that
we looked at there's a sum there's also
means and median
all of those you can compute in num b
and you can also do the square root and
standard deviation
the ravel function very similar to the
flat
to be honest i almost always just use
the flat but you know the ravel has its
own kind of functionality that it does
and then we went into some numpy
practice examples we challenged you to
create a sine wave in numpy and how to
do that we're kind of looking for that a
range remember how we do the a range and
you can
have your beginning value your n value
which they did is three times pi number
pi
and we're going to do intervals of 0.1
and then y just equals the numpy sign of
x there's our math from the math page we
were just looking at remember that it's
right at the top
and uh finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and ones
playing with the different connotations
of z of the numpy array
and then we did a random size and we
played a little bit with how to with the
null values playing with null values
if you're doing any data science you
know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small debt sets
of data you have to factor something in
there like figure out the average or the
median there and then replace it with
that
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it let's start with
just some real general what is pandas
pandas is a tool for data processing
which helps in data analysis it provides
functions and methods to efficiently
manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or hadoop in big data so we're not
talking about big data here but we are
talking about pandas when there is some
connections there's like an interface
going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
big data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column and you have an index and
different that kind of set up and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as a giant excel
spreadsheet that's optimized to run a
larger data on your computer
and then i said it that it's a data
frame so the data structures in pandas
are series one-dimensional arrays and
then we have data frame two dimensional
array and it really centers around the
data frame the series just happens to be
part of that data frame and here's a
closer look at a pandas series series is
a one-dimensional array with labels it
can contain any data type including
integers strings floats python objects
and more so it's very diverse if you
remember from numpy we studied they had
to be all uniform not in pandas and
pandas we can do a lot more and pandas
actually kind of sits on numpy so you
really need to know both of those if you
haven't done the numpy tutorials and you
can see here we have our index one two
three four five and then our data a b c
d and e very straightforward it's just
two columns and we have a nice index
label and a column label for the data
and then a data frame is a
two-dimensional data structure with
labels we can use labels to locate data
and you can see here we had if we go
back one we had our index one two three
four five so in each one of these series
they would share the same index over
there the row index so you have your row
index df dot index and then you have a
column index df.columns and this should
look like i said this would be really
familiar if you've done any work with
spreadsheets excel
so it kind of resembles that this does
make it a lot easier to manipulate data
and add columns delete columns move them
around same thing with the rows so you
have a lot of control over all of this
now we're of course going to do this in
our jupiter notebook you can use any of
your python editors but i highly suggest
if you haven't installed jupyter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on i
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or ides for editing my python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
and then i always let mine sit on
anaconda anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again but you can see here that i
have different tools that i can actually
install in my anaconda including the
jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then i have access to the
environments
and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one the largest world's largest snakes
and then jupiter notebook in this case
jupiter.org and when we're in our i'm
going to go in here to our jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a python 3
and this will open up a python 3
untitled folder
so diving right in let's go ahead and
give this a title pandas tutorial and
we'll go up to cell and we'll change the
cell type to mark down so it doesn't
execute it as actual code
one of those wonderful tools when you
have jupyter notebooks so you can do
demos with this and let's go ahead and
import
pandas
and usually people just call it pd that
has become such a standard in the
industry so we'll go ahead and run that
now we have our pandas has been imported
into our jupyter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the control plus since it's internet
explorer i can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with a new module it's good to check
your version of the module in pandas you
just use the in this case pd dot
underscore underscore version underscore
underscore that's actually pretty common
in most of our python modules there's
different ways to look up the version
but that's one of the more common ones
and we'll go ahead and run that we get
0.23.4
and if we go to the pandas site we see
0.23.4 as the latest release and of
course a reminder that if you're going
to environment you need to install it so
you'll need to do pip install pandas if
you're using the pip installer we'll go
and close out of that
and the first thing you want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
stuff you do in series you can then do
on the whole data set we need to do what
create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query it query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer right
into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go
creating a series from
list
and let's just call this arr equals
and we'll do 0 1 2 3 4. if you remember
from our last one we could easily do
r equals
range of 5 which would be 0 to 4. but
we'll do r equals zero to four and we'll
call this s1 and we'll go pd
and
series is capitalized this one always
throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
gotta watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do arr
so we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series
and then because we're in jupiter we
don't have to put the print statement we
can just put s1 and it'll print out this
series for us
and let's go ahead and run that and take
a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get 0 index row 0
is 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created
and let's do a second series
pd and we'll use the same
datalist and let's go ahead and do order
we'll give it an order
equals oh let's do it this way
let's go
index
equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order
equals and let's do one two three four
five so instead of starting with zero
we're going to give it an order starting
with one we're going to run that and
we'll go ahead and print it out down
here
s2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of 1 2 3 4 5 and that represents 0 1 2 3
4 in the series and we're still data
type integer 64. and very common as
you're missing with numpy arrays is we
can import our numpy as np remember that
from our numpy tutorials we can go ahead
and create a numpy out of random with
the random numbers of five
and let's just see what that end looks
like so we can see what our number looks
like so we have some nice random float
values here 2.33 so on and this from our
last tutorial the numpy tutorial 1 and
2. and instead of calling it order let's
call it index
and we're going to set our index equal
to a b c d and e
well i want to show you that the index
doesn't have to be an integer so it can
be something very different here and
then let's go ahead and create our we'll
just use s2 again and here's our np for
numpy
series capital s
and n is our
np for numpy
pd for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of n
and we want to do our index
equals our index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like s2 is a print it and
let's run that
and we can see here we have a nice
series going on a b c d and e for our
indexes so instead of it being 0 1 2 3
or 4 we can make this index whatever we
want and you can see the numbers here
going down that we randomly generated
from the number array so we use numpy to
create our
panda series right here
and so continuing on with creating our
series this one i use so often we create
a series from a dictionary so we have
our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of 1 b is 2 c of 3 d4
ef5 so each one of those is a key and
then a value and then we're going to use
oh let's use s3
equals pd for pandas
series
and then we want to go ahead and just do
d in here
print out s3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is 1 b
is two c is three d is four e is five
and it's still of integer 64 because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integer 64 type 64. and the
last thing we want to do in the creating
section of our series is to go ahead and
modify the index because we're going to
start modifying all this data so let's
start with modifying the index of the
series and if you remember let's do a
print this time s1
i'll go ahead and run this and the
reason i did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if i put
s1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take s1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously
the number of objects in our index has
to equal the number of objects in our
data and then because it's the last
variable we can go ahead and just do an
s1 and let's run that and you can see
how we went from zero to zero zero one
two three four as our index we've now
altered it to a b c d and e
so this would be much more readable or
might be representational of a larger
database you're working with
so cool tools we've covered creating a
database based on
a basic array python array we've showed
you how to reset the index
then we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series a numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in
the pandas and then we looked on
changing your index so now we have a new
index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do s1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so i'd usually it doesn't
change s1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals s1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there i'll go ahead and take that out
but just a reminder that it's not
actually changing s1 it's just viewing
s1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append
before we do a pen let's just do a quick
kind of fun one we'll do two minus one
and you'll see it covers everything but
the e of course you can do minus two on
this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a two here
cde to the end so it starts at the
second one and another way we can do
this is we can do a minus two over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice so you can see how easy it is
to slice the data and of course
there's no reason to do this but you
could select all of them
if you wanted to view all of them on
there up 32 there's not 32 so it's just
going to show the first three there we
go and then we can also append so i can
take and oh let's create another series
and append one to it and if you remember
we had s3 there's our s3 and we have our
s1 we'll go ahead and do s1
and let's go ahead and do
oh let's call it s4
equals s1
a pin
s3
so we're just going to combine those two
into s4
and if we go ahead and print s4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e 0 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 5 because we
started the data at one so very easy to
append one series to the next
and if we're going to append one series
to the next we need to go ahead and drop
or delete one and drop is a key word for
that and let's just do e our index e and
so if i run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
a b c d there's no e
and remember all these changes if i type
in s4 again
you'll see that s4 still has e in it so
this change does not affect the series
unless you tell it to so i'd have to do
like x s4 equals s4 dot drop e and
there's another way to do that which
we'll show you later on let me just cut
this one out there we go
all right so we've covered all kinds of
cool tools here we have appending we
have slicing we did all the creating
stuff earlier as you can see here on the
setup how easy it is to manipulate the
series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
mark down there we go and run that so
series operations what can we do with
the series
and let's start by creating a couple
arrays we'll call it array one and we'll
do zero through seven and array two six
through six seven eight nine five i
don't know through the five on the end
let's go ahead and run those so those
load up into jupiter
and we'll do this a little backwards
we're going to do s5 equals a panda
series of array two so i'm doing this in
reverse and then when we do s5 you'll
see that we have zero to 4 it
automatically assign the index
67895 for our series
and let's go ahead and do the same and
we'll call this s6 and we'll set this
equal to pd series for
our first array
and if we do an s6 down here to print it
out
we'll see something similar i got zero
through six
zero one two three four five seven for
the data so those are two series we just
created series six five and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so i
can do s5 dot add s6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you never use pandas what do you think
is going to happen with the fact that
this only has five different values in
it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does
and we end up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it
goes oh i can't add this there's nothing
there so it gives us a null return very
different than the numpy that would have
given you an error this instead tells
you there's no value here because we
couldn't generate one so we can easily
add s5 dot add s6 and likewise we can do
s5 dot
sub for subtract
s6
and we'll run that and on the add the
subtract and you guessed it we're going
to do multiply and divide next again you
can see there's null values where it
can't subtract the 2 because there's no
values there to subtract we can also do
s5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this
and you can you can see how they're
multiplied together and then we can also
do the s5 div three letters again
s6
and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
infinity because we have zero in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
an old off of missing data and since
we're in data science let's do s6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an s6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median
or average s6
and let's print max
comma s6
and just like median there's max value
and if we're going to have a max value
we should also have a minimum value so
let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this
and you're starting to see something
that would be generated like say an r
where you're starting to get your
different statistics we have a medium
value of 3 max value of 7 and a minimum
value of 0. and what it does when it
hits these null values if there is no
values in there because we could still
do that we could actually you know what
let's go up here and do
let's pick this one we multiplied let's
go s7
equals
i'll go and print the s7 just so i keep
it nice and uniform so i still have my
s7 down there and run it
and then i want to take the s7
because s7 now has
null values and an infinity value and
let's see what happens
this is going to be interesting because
i want to see what it does with infinity
and we end up with a median of 6 maximum
of 27 and minimum of 0. which is correct
it drops those values so when it gets to
there and it had doesn't know what to do
with them it just drops those values and
then it computes it on the remaining
data on there so it's important to know
when you're making these computations
you're looking at min and max and median
you're not going to know that there's no
values unless you double check your data
for the null values it's a very
important thing to note on there so just
a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our pd series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub min div add
and then we looked at median maximum and
minimum so we're going to go ahead and
jump into the next big topic which is to
create a data frame so now we're going
to go from series and we're going to
create a number of series and bundle
them together to make a data frame
there we go cell type markdown let me go
and run that so we have a nice title on
there it's always good to have a good
title all right so our first data frame
we'll jump in with some stuff that looks
a little complicated we'll break it down
first i'm going to create some dates
and you know what let's just go ahead
and do this i want you to see what that
looks like what i'm creating here i've
created a series of dates pd date range
and we're going to use these for the
index okay so when you look at this
you'll see that it's just basically it
comes out kind of like a basic python
list or a numpy array however you want
to look at it with our different dates
going down and we've generated six of
them and it's going to have whatever
time it is right now on your on the
thing for the date for the time that's
that time stamp right there and then
you'll see we have 11 19 2008 11 20 11
19 and looking into the future there so
that's all this is is generating a
series of dates that we're going to use
as our index and this is a pandas
command so we have a date range which is
nice that's one of the tools hidden in
there in the pandas that you can use
and next we're going to use numpy to go
ahead and generate some random numbers
in this case we'll do the
np.random.random
in 6 comma 4. you can look at this as
rows and columns as we move it into the
pandas and of course you could reshape
this if you had those backwards on your
data but we want the six to match the
rows and we have six periods so our
indexes should match along with the rows
on there and then you know before we do
the next one let's go ahead and just
print out our numpy arrays and see what
that looks like here we have it one two
three four by one two three four five
six four by six
so it's a nice little setup on there and
since working with data frames can be
very visual let's give our columns we
have four columns and we're going to
give them names a b c and d so now we
have columns on there also and then
let's put this all together in a data
frame and we can actually you know what
let's do this since i did it with
everything else let's go ahead and do
columns and you can see there's our
columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1 equals
pandas dot
data frame and note that the d and the f
are capitalized series it was just the s
and i always highlight this because you
don't know how many times these things
get retyped when you forget what's
capitalized on there it's a minor thing
you'll pick it up right away if you do a
lot of it and the first thing we want to
do is we want to go ahead and take our
numpy array because that's what we're
going to create our data frame off of is
the numpy array and then we want our
index equal to our dates so there's our
index in there and then we also have
columns equals
columns
and then finally let's see what that
looks like now remember we had all the
different data that just looked like a
jumble of data we have our column names
and everything else our numpy array kind
of just a jumble array over there four
by six you could sort of read it but
look how nice this looks i mean this is
you come into a board meeting you're
working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is fits in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one i use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data let me just go down a notch so you
can see all the data on there we have an
animal in this case cat cat snake dog
dog cat snake cat dog we have the age so
we have an array of ages we have the
number of visits and the priority was it
a high priority yes
no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what i want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.nand numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a
the first cat b the second cat c the
snake d the dog and so on so we'll go
ahead and create our labels which we're
going to use as an index
and we'll call this df let's do it this
way we'll call this df2
equals pd for pandas
data frame
and then we have our data just like we
did before and we have our index equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very visual and
easy to read
animal age visits priority and then a
through j cats and all your different
animals so on and so on and then when
you do programming a lot of times it's
important to know what the data types
are so we can simply do df2
d types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object and exploring
this this one's very popular let's go
df2
head
and if we print that out the df2 head
returns the first five and we can change
this you don't have to do five you might
want to just look at the top two maybe
you want to look at
let's see let's do six so maybe we'll
look at just the top six in the database
in your data frame
and you can actually this creates
another data frame so i could have a df3
equal to df2 and this now takes the df2
and just the first six values
so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tail it's the same thing
df tail you can look at the last
we'll just do the tell which by default
does five the last five and of course
you can just look at the last three of
those real quick just to see what's at
the end of the data and this is
the tell i love doing the tail of one
because i'll have like the index or
something like that and it will just
show me the last whatever the last entry
was looking at stock values and i might
want to look at just the last five days
of the stock values i can do that with
the data frame tail
and some other key things to look up
are the index so we can do df2 dot index
and i want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if i put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there
so we do
df2.index there's also columns
so we can go ahead and let's do a let's
print this
remember the first one is not going to
show unless i print it and then df2
column so now we can see we have our
indexes
and we have our columns listed here
df2.columns animal age visits priority
it tells you what kind of object it is
or what kind of data type it is and
they're both object
and then finally df2 dot
values and again there's no brackets on
the end of df2.values
because this is an actual object it's
not a callable function so we'll go
ahead and run that and it creates just
displays a nice array a very easy way to
convert this back to a numpy array
basically so before i go into the next
section let's just take a quick look at
what we covered so far with the data
frame we came up here we created our
data frame we did it from a numpy array
first
setting the columns and the index the
index is setting it up is the same as
when we set up the series so that should
look very familiar so is the whole
format the numpy array the index dates
and the columns columns and remember in
our numpy array we're looking at row
comma column so six rows four columns is
how that reads in the data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with a data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up d type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick
we also did index and columns and values
and note these don't have the brackets
on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go and describe
the data so we have
df2.described to do that and we're going
to manipulate it in just a minute but
let's just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits
so looking at our data from up above let
me just go all the way up here
animal age visits priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value
25 or in this group 50 75 and your
maximum value so this look familiar as a
data science setup with your describe
for a quick look at your data frame data
so let's start manipulating this data
frame moving stuff around and we'll
start with transposing and it is simply
capital t for transpose
and when we run that it flips the
columns and the indexes so now the
indexes are all column names and the
columns are all indexes animal age
visits priority
so if we had come in here with our data
shaped wrong up above where we had a 4x6
we can quickly just swap it if we had it
backwards not a big deal and we can also
sort our data something that you can't
do which is more difficult to do with a
lot of other packages in the data frame
it's really easy to do take our data
frame df2 and we're going to sort
underscore values
by equals age and so when we run this
you'll see the default is ascending so
we have 0.52 2.53 and everything else is
organized so if you look at your indexes
they've been moved around because each
index it moves a whole row not just the
one piece of data is not being sorted so
very quick way to sort by age are
different data in the data frame and in
addition to sorting it we can also slice
the data frame so i could do df2 and
this should look familiar from earlier
we'll just do one
to three so we're going to pull out oops
it does help if i use a df instead of
just d and we're going to pull up just
between 1 and 3. so we have no 0 which
is a we have b which is 2 or b which is
1 and c which is 2. so 1 2 and then it
does not include 3 which is the standard
in python and we can even do something
like this we can combine them which is
always fun because remember this returns
a data frame so if i take df2 dot
sort
values and we'll do by
equals age
this is just kind of fun and then i'm
going to slice it
there we go double check my typing and
run it
and now you should see fa because fa are
now 1 and two on there
so you can very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame let's go back to the original
one run there we go and if we can slice
it by row we can also query the data
frame so we can do df2 and this is a
little different because i'm going to
create an array within an array and in
this case we're going to look at oh
let's do
age
comma visits
so look at the different format in here
we have one to three so we've done this
by
slicing by an integer value and then on
here i've done df2 age comma visits in
an array and when i run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get age and visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is i location
which uses the integer location one
comma three
there's a push in pandas to move to this
particular setup
instead of doing just a regular slice
and that's because this can be confusing
when we slice one to three and then we
select agent visits
so there is a push to go ahead and move
to an eye location which does the same
thing you can see here bc it's the same
as up above
there's also copy command so we can do
df3 equals df2 copy we're just going to
create a straight copy of it
and of course if we do df3
it'll be the same as the df2 on there so
df3 equals df2.copy
and then let's do df3 dot is null so
we're looking for null values
and this will return a nice map and
you'll see that everything is false
except when you go up here under the cat
or h they had a null there and so if we
go they have a couple up here also
underneath of let's see the dog okay
there's a bunch of nulls in here there's
d up here so let's look at d down here
and you'll see false true there it is
there's our null value
so we can create a quick chart of null
values you can use this to do other
things we can leverage that null value
to maybe take an average or something
and fill those null spaces with data and
we can also modify the location so
here's our df3
location
and notice this is location not i
location ilocation has i for integer
location uses the
in this case the variables on the left
and what we can do on here and we'll go
and just set this equal to
and then let's um i'll pick a spot
let's go back up here where we had let's
do f
a just let's see what are we looking at
oh here we go let's do f and h
and up here f is set to age of 2.0 and
we find out that that's incorrect data
so we go ahead and switch to df3
equal and then we're going to print out
our df3
and if we go to f and age it is now 1.5
so we're just changing the value in the
df3 and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice
and like it returns another data frame
this changes the actual data frame and
that value in the data frame
so we've covered uh location and eye
location is null making a copy here's
our eye location which is equivalent of
a slice and also selecting columns
so now we want to dive just take a
little detour here and let's look at df3
means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if i run that there's our age
but if i take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal
well those are not integers so it's
really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average i guess you could do a
histogram which probably will look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have
the average or the mean on the age is
3.375
and the mean on visits is 1.9
and let's do df3
visits we'll go ahead and steal the
visits again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we could also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is one
max
so all that functionality is here
i'll just go back to summing it up and
adding it all together so real quick
we've shown you how to take the series
operations and put them into the data
frame and then we can actually this is
interesting one we can just do df3 sum
run and you'll see the different
summations on there
it just combines them i like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals pd series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value cow and owl i don't know why they
picked cal and al in the background
someone must like those animals and of
course we can just do string if we run
that you'll see
leave the r out we'll get an error but
if we put it in there you'll see that we
have a simple series 0 a 1 c 2 d and it
automatically indexes it 0 to 8.
and then we can go string dot lower so
when we're talking about our data frame
in this case or our data series string
in this case we use the string
function str and we're going to make it
lower and if we go ahead and put the
brackets on there and you'll see that
we've gone from capital a capital c so
on to abc and baca cba cow al they were
all lower case already and of course if
you want to go lower you can also do
upper and we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have acd aaa baca
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null alright
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower we're going to jump into a very
important topic i'm even going to give
it its own
header on here because it's such an
important topic what do you do with
missing values
panda has some great tools for that so
we'll dive into those we'll call we'll
work with df4 and if you remember the df
copy from above we're just going to make
a copy of df3 and let's just take a
quick look at the data we're working
with oops df3 forgot the three on there
there we go
so here we have our cats snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll give it the value 4. so i
can run in here and you'll see now that
df4
now has where the n a was it's filled
with the value of four same thing down
here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so i might do a mean
age
equals df4 and then we want to go ahead
and do age
and dot mean
and then i'll do something like this df4
i only want to select the age and i want
to fill that
with the mean
age i run in there and you'll see that
our df4h now has the means in there just
a quick way of showing you how you can
combine these let me go back to our
original one there we go and run that
and keeping with good practices df5
equals df3 dot copy
and we'll print our df5 which should be
the original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
i'm going to simply drop in a
and we're going to use how equals any so
i'm going to drop any row that has
missing data in it and you'll see we had
d here with missing data and h
and then let's go ahead and see what df5
looks like when we do that
there we go and there it is d is gone
and so is h so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power the data you
got
so just a quick look at processing null
values
or missing values you can fill them
usually with the means some people use
medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is i so love data frames for this
file operations
it saved me so much time because they
have so many different tools for
bringing data in and saving data
so we're looking at the data frame file
operations it's really streamlined i
don't know how many times they'll go on
to
different data downloads and they'll
have panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a csv so we have df3 to csv or animal
and let me just show you what the folder
is going into
right now i have some untitled and a few
things in here but nothing labeled
animal so we go ahead and run this
and this has now saved the animal to
my hard drive and you can now see the
animal folder up here and if i let's do
edit with a notepad oh let's open up
with just a regular notepad there we go
or wordpad if i open that up you can see
it's comma separated our titles they
don't have an index on the categories on
the top and the index comma then all the
different data is separated by commas
standard csv file on there and if we're
going to send it to csv and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore csv
and it's just the name of the file we're
sending it to you can also put the
complete path by default it's going to
go whatever the active directory this
program is running on that's why those
other folders are in there so we have
our df3 to csv and then if we're going
to put it in there we want to also get
it back out and we'll call this one df
underscore animal equals pd read
underscore csv
i always have to remember as two
underscore csv and read underscore csv i
always want to do like a capital in
there and not the underscore we're going
in here again it's the active directory
so if i now do print out my df animal
and let's just do the ahead we only want
to look at the first three lines so if
we go ahead and run this
we'll see the first three lines and they
should match up here what we saved to
our csv
so very easy to save and import from our
csv files on here
and it turns out df
3 also has a 2 xl they actually have a
lot of different formats but you know
old school
excel was real popular for so long still
is we can go ahead and save it as animal
dot xlsx we're going to call the sheet
named sheet1
and then i can also do df we'll call it
animal 2
animal 2 and this one's going to come
from in the same format on here there we
go so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet1 that's where it's coming from
index columns equals none so we're not
going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
will just assign that zero on up on your
indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because there's
no values in here and we want to just
make sure that they're marked as n a
and we'll go ahead and just print out
the animal animal 2 there we go and
let's run that let's make this let's
just do the whole thing so we'll go
ahead and run that and it probably
doesn't help that i completely forgot
the read
so animal 2 equals pd.reed
excel there we go excel so now we go
ahead and run it
and what we expect is happening here we
have the same data frame on here and if
i flick back to my folder you can now
see that we have the animal one of these
is in excel and one of these is a csv on
here and so there's our two file types
on there and they have other formats
these are just the two most common ones
used and i don't know how many times
i've had stuff from excel i need to pull
out if you've ever played with excel
it's a nightmare in the back end because
of the way they do the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there put your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where really important part of data
science is so let's go ahead and bring
in our tools we're going to do import
numpy as np we want to make sure we have
our amber sign matte plot library in
line this just lets jupiter know that
we're going to print it on this page if
you're using a different ide you don't
really necessarily need that but this
does help it displays correctly in
jupiter notebook and if you remember for
earlier we could create a uh we're going
to call it ts we're going to create a
pandas which are cute cuddly creatures
versus a pandem short for pandemonium no
so we have ts equals pd series and we're
just going to create a random
setup of 50. we'll do an index we'll set
it equal to the panda's date range today
periods equals 50. so the 50 should
match and i want you to notice something
here i did not import the matplot
library why because it's already in
there pandas already has its built-in
connection and interface with matplot
library so you don't have to import it
and we'll go ahead and do ts equals ts
dot
cumulative sum we're gonna do the
cumulative sum
so a little reformatting there and we'll
go ahead and plot it and let's take a
look at what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one
so what we've done here we plotted a
basic series just a single row of data
and we've set indexes on there but we
can also do the whole data frame on
there and let's see what that looks like
so first let's go ahead and create the
data frame we have here random numbers
so we're going to do 50 by 4 and then
we'll go ahead and create columns a b x
and y just because we can index is the
ts.index on there so we're gonna use the
same index as before
just to keep it nice and uniform we've
already generated the dates to go with
it and then we can do just like we did
with the series
we can also do with the data frame
df equals df cumulative sum
so we're going to sum the whole data
frame and then we'll do simply df plot
and let's put that in and let's go ahead
and run this and look how easy and quick
that was to generate a nice graph with
all the different data on there so we
have our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh i think i mentioned
stock earlier because i've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a stock b stock x y
whatever it is and you can put them all
on one chart and see how they
what they look like next to each other
and this isn't too far off from what
some of those graphs looks like and this
is just randomly generated so stock has
a lot of randomness in it which is one
of the reasons i actually play with it
for doing some of my models on for
testing them out
now there are a lot of features in
pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like i didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a csv and from an excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do
we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
changes to a markdown and run that
so how would you remove repeated data
using pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's feeding
from one location and instead of noting
that it's repeated the date like oh
let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have the stocks from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down
so let's start by creating a quick
database or data frame not a database i
keep saying database it's a data frame
and we'll just make this data frame has
using our dictionary going in this data
frame only has one data series in it
which is fine so if we do df to print it
out you'll see a
one two two two two four five four five
six seven so on so how would you remove
that well there is a neat feature in
data frames called shift along with
another feature that lets us
select just certain date information
and we'll go with
the location function put that in
brackets remember that from above
location and then in the location let me
just spread this out a little bit so
it's real easy to read in fact i'm going
to go upscale on that since we're doing
some a little bit more complicated here
what you can see on this on the location
is i have dfa.gov
so this is going to shift up one by
default you can actually change this to
two or three you can even do a minus one
and it shifts the other way but it's
going to shift up by one by default
that's going to say if that does not
equal
df of a
then we want that and if you look down
here we had one two two two two two when
we run this logic on here and we do the
shift
it now gets rid of all the duplicates so
we went from one two two two two four
four five whatever it was here it is one
two two two four four four five five
five six six six two one two four five
six seven eight and you'll see on the
index it just deletes them out of there
so the index stays the same obviously
you don't want the dates to change if
you're working with an index dated setup
so it just deletes those duplicates out
of there this is just a quick way to
introduce you to
one the fact that you can add logic
gates into here and two the eye location
allows you to use shift so there's the
shift function and then the i location
selects that based on true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot
hopefully you'll take this beyond that
and start combining these different
things and you can create long strings
and really explore your data generate
some nice graphs if you're in jupyter
notebook it's a great demo to show
others
and i didn't know this about jupiter
notebook you can do this in jupyter
notebook and then you can download and i
always i never really looked too closely
at all the downloads which you can
download as an html and post it to your
blog so it's got a neat feature in there
but any of this is really powerful tool
all of this is really powerful tools for
doing your data science
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
today we're going to study the matte
plot library and the python code so
what's in it for you
what is mat plot library types of plots
plotting graphs and sub graphs adding a
graph inside a graph graph parameters
title label legend line graphs line
types color and transparency canvas grid
and axis range 2d plots scatter step bar
fill between radar chart histogram
contour image 3d surface image and then
we'll hit a practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matte plot
library map plot library is an open
source drawing library which supports
rich drawing types it is used to draw 2d
and 3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the maplight library
that we can't even cover them all today
but we'll hit the main one so you have a
good understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy i
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupiter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupiter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that and
you'll look at any of our tutorials i
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up jupiter and anaconda i
myself use jupiter through anaconda in
fact let's go ahead and open that up and
just take a look at this see what that
looks like you can see your anaconda
navigator if you install it it will
automatically install the jupyter
notebook but that also installs a lot of
other things i know some people like the
qt console for doing python or spyder
i've never used them i actually use
notepad plus plus as one of my editors
and then i use the jupiter notebook a
lot because it's so easy to have a
visual while i'm programming an even
simple script in python i'll take it
from the jupyter notebook and then do a
save as you can always go under file and
you can download as a python program so
that will download it as an actual
python versus the ipython that this
saves it as so let's go ahead and dive
in and see we got going here and let's
go ahead and put matplot library
tutorial and i'm going to turn this cell
into a markdown so it doesn't actually
run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out that we're in version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're gonna graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us
and there is a lot of ways to create
data but we're going to use the np.line
space so we're going to create a numpy
array and the way you read this
is we're going to create numbers between
0 and 10 and we're going to create 25 of
these numbers we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus 2 and let's just take a look we're
going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see what we got going on here
so we have our x coordinates which is 0
0.4 0.83 etc and you can look at this as
an xy plot so we have 0 we have 2. we
have 0.416 we have
2.17 and just as a quick reminder we're
going to print np array x comma
y.reshape 25 comma 2. and the reason i
want to do this is i want to show you
something here
a lot of times a program returns
x comma y and it's an array of x comma y
x comma y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pie
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data and so we use our
from up here where we imported pi lab we
take our pi lab and the key under there
is plot for plotting a line and then we
want our x coordinates and our y
coordinates and we'll throw in r and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company's
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs okay
so let's take our pi lab and create a
sub plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values
and we're going to represent by rows
columns and indexes and let's do one two
one so it's going to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to plot data onto the
subplot so the order is very important
and we're going to stick with our x
comma y and let's do this we're going to
add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row one column two
and if we're going to do that let's do
up another one pi
lab.subplot and if we're going to do row
one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're gonna add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pilab
subplot there we go by lab we got to go
ahead and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switch them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's depreciated
there's another way to do it but most
people just ignore that warning because
it's not going to go away anytime soon
now that's using the same setup what
happens if we do
instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to 2
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two i squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers till you
get a handle on them because
you know you have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where there you go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right
hopefully hit the wrong one that's why
let's go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the
where we have column and row two and the
two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fit we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize the
subplot add the subplot in rows and
columns and all kinds of different
things with this you can do let's look
at that code and see exactly what's
going on and i want you to notice that
there's fig which is the actual canvas
in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas is pd and numpy
array is np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to
fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one
and so we can go ahead and i'm just
going to put some stuff in there i got
point five point one point eight point
eight so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
fifty percent ten percent eighty eighty
percent but it's a control it's going to
control your left and your right along
with the width and the height so the
width and the height we're gonna use 80
percent and we're going to have like a
little indent on the left and the right
and this should look familiar from above
x's dot plot x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use a axis instead of ax es i
don't know where that came from but this
looks identical to the one we had up
above so here's our axis plot x comma y
of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axes is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs let me
put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different temptation here we have fig
comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals two so if you
remember before this that we did we had
one row with two different graphs on it
we're going to do the same thing but
know how we did this here's our figure
our canvas and our axes we're going to
create actually two different axes we're
going to create row 1 column 2. and so
axis is an array of information so we
can simply do
let's do x in axes
this will look familiar x dot plot we're
going to do x comma y we'll go ahead and
make a red keep everything looking the
same remember nice uniform graphs
everything looks the same and if we go
ahead and run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's see
if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get an attribute error because
it's trying to scrunch everything
together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows two and columns
equals one you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture
or graph
inside another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation
so let's start by uh fig let's create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas
we set that equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and
this here similar numbers we used before
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axis is so this is going to be
the big
axes and let's do axes two equals
another figure at axes and then point
two point five point four point three
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axes so axes1 dot plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red
and then let's go axes2 dot plot
and let's reverse them y comma x comma
green there we go doing what i told you
not to do you shouldn't be swapping axes
around and plotting your data in five
different directions because it's
confusing let's go ahead and run this
and see what this looks like and then
let's talk a little bit about this we
talked about the 0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2
0.5 is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one
that actually is they had it down at
left right i thought this was wrong it's
actually how far from the bottom let me
switch that on here bottom there we go
so we had here on this we can go ahead
and put that back to point five and run
that and this is point three let's make
this point three also and that is the
width and then of course there's the
height we can make that really tiny
let's see let's do 0.2
let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there we make it
even smaller 0.2 by 0.2 and as you can
see you can get stuck playing with this
to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas size so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at
and what we can do is we can change the
figure size to 16 by nine and let me run
that and show you what that looks like
so it fills the whole screen and then if
you are normally when you're working on
the screen you don't worry too much
about this but we can set the dpi to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good solid
number to use your dots per inch and you
can see it drills a nice it draws a nice
large canvas here which is 16 by nine
and then the dpi is 300 on here it's a
little higher quality and just out of
curiosity i wonder how long it takes to
draw something double that size 600 and
you can see here where at 600 dpi it's
going to take a while there it goes just
because it's utilizing a lot more
graphics on there and let me just go
back to the 300 now we'll actually do
let's do a 100 you're not going to see a
difference on this because it is web
based graphics are pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our
axis on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the dpi let me take this
all out let me just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this
one things we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since i put this on the
axis it's the main title for the whole
graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and then we
run that and of course we can also do
upper size a little bit and see what's
going on a little better so here we have
x label x if you come down here you'll
see our x label and our y label we can
of course change this to x
label you can change this to y
be whatever you want on here of course
and our title graph there we go run so
here we have our title graph our y label
and our x label all set up on our nice
little plot and then before we move on
to the next section let's do one more
thing on here we have a thing called the
legend and we're gonna do we're gonna
set our ax legend label one label two up
here it's a format for it but let's go
down here and actually use it i'm gonna
do two different plots we're gonna have
axes plot x by x times x squared and x
cubed and if i run this you'll see it
puts two nice graphs on the setup on
there but it's nice to have a legend
telling you what's going on so for the
legend we can actually do axes since we
have the two plots legend and on here
we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom location one i can't remember
where that's at there we go upper right
so each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kinda have to play with them
or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title of the graph
the y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title of the graph looks a
little fuzzy so i might in a web setup
put the dpi up a couple notches maybe
put it at 200 100 might work fine just
so you know something to notice on here
when you're playing with these different
things we had our subplots dpi equals oh
let's do 200 to see what that looks like
so you can see it now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure in our axis equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see
and let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus one so it's
just going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and axis dot plot
x x
plus three this looks like we're doing
nearest neighbor setup we're showing how
it
located data putting your lines on there
between the nearest neighbors there we
go so it draws a nice little graph with
three lines on it one of the things we
can do is we can control the alpha on
this oops and you can actually see the
um when they did these lines it
automatically pulls in different colors
for your setup so there's some automatic
automatic things going on in there and a
lot of times we do that comma r where
we're going to do color equals red
another notation on here let's go ahead
and run this now we have a bright red
line down there and with the matte plot
library you're not limited to red you
can also use the one of many different
color references as you see here with
the pound sign 1155
which just is just blue and we can do
the same thing with another color on
here which turns out to be green i can
just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to say what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5 and oh you
know what instead of squaring it let's
take it to the 0.5 power that'll be kind
of interesting to see what that does
we'll just go to keep it squared there
we go
and run that and let's go back and look
at this where it crosses over and the
first thing you see right here is on the
blue it's kind of light blue now you can
see how the two colors add together you
get almost a purple on there so i can
clearly see where the red crosses the
blue line and then the green just blanks
it over because i didn't do any
opaqueness no alpha on there
so this is great if you have lots of
data that crosses over and you need to
be able to track those lines better
we'll go ahead and do this 0.5 and we'll
run that oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as the
default is one solid so we can change
this all to point eight let me just do
that
oops 58 there we go run
oops i must have hit a wrong button
there let me try that again i actually
get rid of a bracket and let's go ahead
and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at
eighty percent instead of fifty percent
when you can do less that's kind of fun
although at some point the lanes kind of
fade
so point five is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at point three and you can easily
see where they cross over and just like
you can play with the colors we can play
with line width and you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
if i run this they should all appear the
same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line width
width equals
0.25
and let's just copy and paste that down
here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one just make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a point five
a one are one point five and two which
is twice the width of the one and if
we're going to do different sizes we had
different colors we had our alpha scheme
let's take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width
let's look at styles and something to
know here you can actually abbreviate
this with lw so line width can also be
point let's just do everything point two
and let's set up a line style we'll do
the first one dashes let me just paste
that down here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot let's do the dash
dot here and a colon here there we go
and there's a lot of different options
we'll look at a few more as we go down
for different ways of highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything is a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus
4 so it goes right on the top then do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line and we're going to take the
line and we're going to set dashes so
look i've changed some of the notation
here for my line and my ax plot so i can
set my line comma equal to x plot and
then i can change the line settings this
way and when i run this let me run that
on here you'll see the 5 10 15 10
creates a series of dashes
that are buried in link
link in this case they alternate between
a short dash and a long dash we can play
with these numbers curiosity always has
me what happens when you play with the
numbers just to see what they look like
let's do this let's paste this down here
i'll do two of these just because
they're kind of fun to play with and
let's change this from 10 to
3 and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
4. and let's run that and you can see
the differences in the lines oops very a
little bit confusing on there because i
forgot to change the lines are all on
top of each other so let me change that
really quick here and let's run that and
now you can see here's our original
dashed line alternating when i change
these numbers on the second one the very
end value to three you can see now we
have dashes of five let's see i'm going
to guess this is a dash is a five skip
ten dashes of fifteen skip three and
then it goes back to the beginning dash
is five dashes skip ten fifteen dashes
skip three and of course the last one we
just switched up a little bit it looks a
lot more uniform because i'm using two
sets of ten or if i did something like
this and change it to thirty it really
becomes pronounced as far as the
distances between them and instead of
four let's go oh let's put 30 here also
30 by 30 there we go really pronounced
on that one and let's look at one more
important group for plotting our data
and in this we're going to here's our
plot we started with with the x plus one
x plus two x plus three and did it in
blue on this one's three or four
different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this let's see it puts a dot for each of
these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option dots is
most common i'll actually like the dots
the best if we do the plus sign you see
it puts a nice crosshairs or plus sign
on there and we can do a marker there's
a number of different markers you can
use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one s for square o for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh number one so
if you run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do
marker
size equals two and
change that to five and run that and you
can see here it's a nice little tiny dot
versus uh the size dot here this is
interesting because it said two i
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we have marker size so we
also have marker face
we'll set that equal to red of course we
need to take change the so it's up one
notch we'll run that whoops must have
mistyped something on here and i did
it's marker face color equals red and so
when i run that you can now see i have
the squares on there with the marker
face color of course we can mix and
match these
come down here and we'll make this
instead of let's make this plus seven
and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other of course if
we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge
generally though you want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go that's
too small to even see the face so four
you can start to see the face on there
around four and maybe an eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line with different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals dash you
can bring this down here also to the
markers and then we added markers in
just entered a circle a
plus sign the square a little tick which
uses a one then we had a marker size and
a marker color face and we combine those
you see we get a nice different series
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here and have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to i changed it to red and blue
so you get very precise on the color if
you have very specific color set that
you need to match your website or
whatever you're working on
all those are tools in the matplot
library so we have
one more piece to formatting the graph
so we want to show you and then we have
two big sections we're going to go over
the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data
so this first primer is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're going to do a figure size of 10
comma five this should all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're going to go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared x x cubed line with two so
we're gonna go ahead and just plot two
graphs right on top of each other
without doing multiple plots on here and
we'll set the grid equal to true one
here let's go ahead and run that and you
can see here our two plots with the x
value going across
and i'm going to do something similar
and by the way as you can just if you
look at it you can see the grid on there
that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're going to take the same
data for axes one so we have our plot of
x x squared x and x cubed line with 2
and this time we're going to take our
axis 1 and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
zero comma
sixty i'm just making these numbers up
the guys in the back actually made them
up i'm just using their numbers
we're gonna set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as don't
forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit zero to sixty so we're looking at
just the lower part of this curve here
up to here and we have the x limit two
to five so that starts right here at two
and you can see very different graphs
this is kind of nice because you could
actually put one of these on top of the
other if you wanted to draw focus to one
part of a graph remember how we did that
earlier one inside the other but just a
quick note you can easily limit your
graph and re-kind of reshape the way it
looks quite easily and we can also add
that grid down there if you want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at four common graphs we'll put
them side by side so we'll do a figure
our axes equals plot subplots one four
columns and then figure size hopefully
it'll fit nicely on here it seems to do
pretty good on here and i'll go and just
run that since we're in there run you'll
see i have my four blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axis of zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our in
we can do x or n there we go and let's
go ahead and do axes set title scatter
i've already did that we're just going
to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are i have a lot
of random numbers connected to them
that's why they do them on there and so
the bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
exes one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n
n times 2 r n squared n times 2 n
squared line width equals 2 and if we
run that it creates a nice step up
see so we've got a scatter plot we've
got a steps plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run
and if we take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i've used the step craft very much
there's certain other certain i guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very concrete
objects somebody how many people are
wearing yellow hats that kind of thing
but if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and do the last one which i see a
lot more in the sciences certainly using
the data science but more like for
mapping i saw publication on
solar flares and they were discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different look so we're
going to do the fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor and
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i can't find
a reason to use one now so the first
line for doing a radar chart we have to
add axes into the figure and with this
this actually creates our
oh this let's run it so you can see what
it creates it creates a nice looks like
you're on a submarine and you're
tracking the hunt for red october or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here i'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data t equals np line space
and this is 0 to 2 times np times pi so
if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate a 100 points
so this is just a thing of data we're
putting together then we simply do an ax
dot plot and in this case let's do t
comma t
which would be a diagonal line on a
regular chart and we'll give it a nice
color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t
times 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we could do t times
two spirals that a little quicker so
it's kind of just a fun i've like i said
i've never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or in an
airplane
and none of this would be complete if we
didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh do
i use a histogram so much
and we'll use our numpy that we have set
as np to generate oh looks like we have
a hundred thousand variables we're going
to set equal to n and of course we
create our figure and our axes subplots
1 2 figure size 12 14. so we're going to
look at two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there and then
this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here so we generated an array here of
data 1000 random arrays it looks like
they're mostly between -4 and 4
and then it adds up each one it says 0
you have
35 000 that are zero so that's what's
most common on here and we have 20 000
that are somewhere in this range right
here between the minus two and well it
looks like one and minus two and
somewhere between zero and 1 there's 30
000 numbers so all this is saying is
this is how common these variables are
and this gives you this point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram and you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your array just like you did on the
other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has that prints the data
out for us and here's our whoops
must have missed oh there we go it
doesn't help that i put it over the old
one there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
and we could set that for 5
and run that
and then we have our 5 on there and we
go ahead and take the cumulative equals
true out just so you can see what that
looks like and let me run that on here
too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look
wait it shifts at all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's
accumulative detail the histogram the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
and we'll import matplot.c
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can even do your own color map
they're pretty diverse and of course our
plt we're going to our pi plot and to
generate our different data we're going
to create a delta
0.025 and we'll start with x when we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our x y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for z1 we'll do a z2 so
we have two different areas and z equals
z1 minus z2 times two
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z if you remember x y
we created as our x and y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
these are x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components
x and y being the coordinates while z is
going to be our actual height since
we're doing a contour map so we created
our contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represent zero maybe that's sea
level and then moving on up you have
your contours of 0.5 and then minus 1
and different setups little hills i
guess if it's minus that's like a pit so
i guess you're going down into a pit at
minus 5 and -1 but on the other side you
can see you're going up in levels so
here's a mountaintop and here's like a
basin of some kind and in data science
this could represent a lot of things
this could also be representing two
different values and maybe profits and
loss i don't know if i'd ever really do
that as a contour map but i'm sure you
can be creative and find something fun
to do with a contour map and then we're
going to look at one last map which is
the 3d map and those are can be really
important as a final product because
they can show so much additional
information that you can't fit on
two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image and so we're
going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14
by 6. that's a good fit on the screen
we'll go ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before
where we had x y and z capital x y and z
so we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since it's also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and our capital x
capital y capital z so there's our data
coming in and we're going to add some
settings in here we're going to do r
stride 4 c stride 4 and line width 0.
i'll show you what that is here in just
a minute let's go ahead and run that so
we can see our graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph so let's take a
little bit time to explore some of these
numbers we have going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these i'm
gonna change this to five
and it's gonna give me an error let's
change it to one
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead and you're
going to see how it starts reshaping the
size and how it fits on the screen
and we'll change the first one to two
we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there but again that changes
the size now fits on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what we're talking about here this is
column width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole set up on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people still talk about heat maps
what is a heat map well it is simply a
color map that's all it is so if you
ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into let me go
back up here here we go this one has
different colors for the different
values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image into nice
colors represented by a heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case so we've covered a lot of
things on matplot and that brings us
cover all the basics so that brings us
to practice example and this is going to
be the challenge for you and let me go
ahead and change our cell
cell type mark down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a path python
program to create a pie chart of the
popularity of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our map library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c sharp c
plus plus so those are six categories
and then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent java 17.6 and
i don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled
my guess is that they might have just
been made up because i don't know
python's really that much more popular
than the other ones maybe specific to
data science because python is very
popular in data science right now
because it has so many options the only
other program that's highly used and
exclusively for data science is r so
python's big and python also does a lot
more it's a full programming language
where r is primarily for data science
they didn't put r in here so we have
python we have java we have our php and
you can see the different values of
given it or different percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that you could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt dot pi
and we're plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pie not too
exciting there and then we'll go ahead
and put in all the extras i talked about
explode we can explode one of the values
out so here's our explode equals explode
labels as languages because we want to
know what the different colors mean
here's our colors equals colors
our auto picture and this is standard
print format so that's a python setup on
there and that's just going to put the
value on the pie slice and then we're
going to add shadow because it just
looks cooler with a shadow gives a
little 3d look and we'll do a start
angle of 140. let's go ahead and run
this and take a look and see what comes
out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
it's pushed out there's our shadow a 3d
effect
and then we started at 140. we could
also rotate this let's just do this
angle
90.
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pie slice has moved
up a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run it'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that to appear on the
left because people read left to right
and so it draws a focus onto in this
case python and how great python is i'm
a little biased we're teaching a python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the map plot library dot pi
plot set up and if you go underneath
there the different functions on there
you can look this up on their website
you'll see a full list and this is why
it's so important to go through a
tutorial like this because this list is
just so massive trying to figure out
like here's our bar plot there's a bar h
you can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here hist
there's also the his 2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive
we've covered all the basic ones so that
you know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library in
the next project we'll understand how to
perform data analysis using uber data
set from new york city so let me show
you the data set first
so this is the data set that we'll be
using for our analysis you can see
this data set
has around 5 lakhs 64 516 rows
it has information about
uber bookings in the new york city
you have the date and time column when
the booking was done
or you can see when the pickup or the
trip was made
next
we have the latitude and longitude
information basically defining the
location from where the uber was booked
the last column is the base column it
has data regarding tlc based company
code affiliated with the uber pickup
that is the base that dispatched the
uber
now let me take you straight to my
jupyter notebook where i have
implemented this project
so i have my code ready i'll run through
each cell of code and tell you what it
does
in the process we'll also learn some of
the functionalities of python 2.
first
let's start by importing the libraries
so first we're importing numpy library
as np
panda as a speedy now numpy is used for
numerical computation
pandas is used for preprocessing and
data manipulation finally we have
matplotlib and c bond for data
visualization and exploratory data
analysis
so let me hit shift enter to run this
cell
okay
now
let's go ahead and import our uber data
set so it's a csv file for that i'm
using the pandas library and read
underscore csv function
and inside this function i provided the
location where the data file is you can
see this is my location
followed by the data set name this is
the name of my data set
and the extension as well that is dot
csv
let me hit shift enter to run this cell
now we have successfully
imported our data set
now to display the head of the data set
i'll write uber
dot head
this is the function which is used to
display the head of the data set
now the dot head function will display
the top five rows from this data set
there you go so we have our first
five rows from the data set
now
if you want to display some additional
information about the data set
you can use info function
so let me hit
shift enter to run this cell
you can see
the info function gives you the total
number of rows and columns in the data
set
you can see we have 5 lakh 64 516
entries that is rows and now we have a
total of four columns
and you can see all the columns listed
here date time latitude longitude base
and we also have the data type for each
of these columns
now moving ahead
in the following cell
we'll check if there are any missing
values or null values in all the columns
for that i have defined a function
called
num missing
and it has one argument that is x
i am using the is null function to
return the total sum of null values
in the final print statement i have used
pandas library and
apply method now this apply method takes
a function and applies it to all the
values of pandas series
let's
run this cell
you can see
none of the columns have any missing
values it says 0 0 0 and 0 which means
there are no missing values in any of
the
columns next
there's another method to find null
values
where you can use is any function so let
me show you how to do that
i'll write uber which is my data frame
dot
is an e is my function
and
i'll use the sum function
let me run this
there you go it has written the same
results indicating there are no null
values or missing values
now
we are interested to extract some
additional information from the data
so i am converting the date time column
into a data frame using two underscore
datetime function
and i have my format specified you can
see it here
next
i am finding the day of week num which
means i want to know a particular day
falls on which week number so 0 for
monday 1 for tuesday 2 for wednesday and
so on
you can see i have used dt dot
day of week method
similarly
you can also find the weekday name
that is if a particular day is a monday
or a tuesday or a sunday or anything
and for that i have used dt dot weekday
underscore name
now let me extract two more information
that is the day number and the hour of
the day at which the trip was made
so i'll write uber which is my data
frame name i'll give square brackets and
inside that i pass in my column names
say
d num
and that will be equal to
my data frame that is uber
followed by
a column name that is date slash
time
and i'll use the method dt
dot
day
similarly
to find the r
i'll write uber
within square brackets i give my column
name r of
day
that will be equal to
uber
followed by the original column name
date slash time
and
the method i'll use is
dt dot r
let's run this
okay
now
let me display the head of the data set
once again
so i'll write
uber
dot head
you can see
towards the right we have our new
columns added
that did not exist in our original data
set
now you can also display the save of the
data set
now the shape will return the total
number of rows and columns present so
i'll use uber dot
shape
you can see we have 5 lakhs 64 516 rows
and eight columns now earlier if i go on
top we had
four columns
now there are eight columns in total
you can also
find out all the unique base code names
from where the uber was dispatched
so let me show you how to do that i'll
write uber
and inside square brackets i'll give my
column as base
and give the unique function
if i run this
you can see we have five different base
code names
now
coming to our first visualization of the
project
here
we'll see the total count of uber trips
from each piece
for that i've used the cbon library and
cat plot function
in the x axis i have my base column
defined
i have passed my data frame name that is
uber
and kind i have given as count that is i
want to count the number of bookings at
each base
so let me run it
this might take some time
there you go
you can see on the screen we have a nice
bar graph here
the x axis shows the count of trips for
each base code
so base
had the highest number of trips or
bookings in april 2014
and base
had the lowest number of bookings
in the next cell
let's explore another feature of pandas
library that is to create a pivot table
for that i have used
pivot underscore table function
for index i am using the column names d
of week num and day of week
values are passed my base column and the
aggregate function i have used is count
now the cell of code will create a table
to understand the total number of trips
for each day of the week
let me run this
you can see in april 2014
wednesdays had the highest number of
trips which is around 1 lakh 8 000
while sundays had the lowest 51
251.
now that makes sense because sunday is a
holiday in new york and people would
like to spend time at home
now
let's visualize the pivot table in the
form of a bar plot
so
i'll write
uber underscore week underscore
data
dot
i'll use the plot function
inside plot function i'll give kind
is bar so i want a bar plot
and i'll define my figure size
and i'll give
equal to
let's say
8 comma 6
run this cell
there you go
as we saw above
wednesday had the highest number of uber
pickups while sunday had the lowest
similarly
let's visualize the bookings based on r
of the day
so i have created a pivot table and then
i am trying to plot a line graph
let's run this
okay
you can see the trend
at midnight the number of trips are less
it slowly increases early in the morning
and during the evening time
uber bookings are higher
so you can see around
4 in the afternoon to
7 in the evening uber trips attain a
peak and trips gradually decrease after
8 pm in the evening
moving ahead
let's now analyze the number of uber
bookings based on each day in the april
month of 2014
so i have created my pivot table and
then i am trying to plot a bar graph you
can see i have kind equal to bar
let's run this
okay
we have our bar graph ready
now this bar graph depicts 30th of april
had the highest number of uber bookings
followed by
4th of april that is this one
now i can
show you in the next two cells of code
now in the current cell
we are basically counting the number of
trips for each day in april month
i have grouped each day number using the
group by function and used the apply
function to count rows let's run it
so i have all the day numbers listed and
the total number of trips that were made
for each day of the month
now let me sort the bookings for each
day in ascending order
so i'll write
by underscore date
underscore
sorted
equal to by underscore
date
dot
i'll use the function sort underscore
values
now to display i'll again use by
underscore
date
sorted
let me run it
now we have
arranged this in ascending order
the results tell us that
20th of april had the lowest number of
trips
while
30th of april had the highest
followed by
4th of april now you can also create a
histogram to analyze the pickups by ours
let's run this cell
i've used the hist function for this
okay
so we have our histogram ready
now this histogram is similar to
the line graph that we plotted above
this one
now let's create a cross table to
analyze uber bookings based on day of
weeknum and r of t
so here i have used group by function
split function apply as well as unstack
function
let me run this
there you go so this is my
cross table ready on the top we have day
of
week num that is zero for monday one for
tuesday
two for wednesday
for saturday 6 for sunday
and then here we have the r of d
now let me tell you how to read this
table for example
at 11 am
on tuesday there were
2949 trips
if i scroll down
let's consider
this one
at 2 pm
on
sundays there were 2934
trips
let's move on to our final section of
the demo
here we'll create a heat map to analyze
bookings in terms of r of day and day of
week number
for this i am using
sns.heatmap function
the brightest spot will tell the day or
the r
with the highest frequency of trips
let's run this
there you go
we have a nice heat map ready
the dark regions depict the frequency of
trips were less
while the bright regions so the highest
number of trips
so if i come down
these are the bright regions
so if you look at this heat map we can
conclude
that
5 pm on
wednesdays had the maximum number of
trips because this region is the
brightest
now this was a simple and interesting
project that you can create in your
final semester
in this session we are going to learn
about databases
how data is stored in relational
databases and we'll also look at some of
the popular databases
finally we'll understand various sql
commands on mysql server
now let's get started with what is a
database
so according to oracle a database is an
organized collection of structured
information or data that is typically
stored electronically in a computer
system
a database is usually controlled by a
database management system or dbms
so it is a storage system that has a
collection of data
relational databases store data in the
form of tables that can be easily
retrieved managed and updated
you can organize data into tables rows
columns and index it to make it easier
to find relevant information
now talking about some of the popular
databases
we have mysql database we also have
oracle database then we have mongodb
which is a nosql database
next we have microsoft sql server next
we have apache casendra which is a free
and open source nosql database and
finally we have postgresql
now let's learn
what is sql so sql is a domain specific
language to communicate with databases
sql was initially developed by ibm
most databases use structured query
language or sql for writing and querying
data sql commands help you to store
process analyze and manipulate databases
with this
let's look at what a table is
so this is how a table in a database
looks like
so here you can see
the name of the table is players
on the top you can see the column names
so we have the player id the player name
the country to which the player belongs
to and we also have the goals scored by
each of the players so these are also
known as fields in a database
here each row represents a record or a
tuple
so if you have the player id which is
103 here the name of the player is
daniel he is from england and the number
of goals here score is seven
so you can use sql commands to query
update insert records and do a lot of
other tasks
there are mainly four types of sql
commands
so first we have data definition
language or ddl
so ddl commands change the structure of
the table like creating a table deleting
a table or altering a table all the
commands of ddl are auto committed which
means it permanently save all the
changes in the database
we have create alter drop and truncate
as ddl commands
next
we have data manipulation language or
dml
so dml commands are used to modify a
database it is responsible for all forms
of changes in the database dml commands
are not auto committed which means it
can't permanently save all the changes
in the database
we have select
update
delete and insert as dml commands now
select command is also referred to as
dql or data query language third we have
data control language or dcl
so dcl commands allow you to control
access to data within the database
these dcl commands are normally used to
create objects related to user access
and also control the distribution of
privileges among users
so we have grant and revoke which are
the examples of data control language
finally we have something called as
transaction control language or tcl
so tcl commands allow the user to manage
database transactions
commit and roll back our example of tcl
now let's see the basic sql command
structure
so first
we have the select statement
so here you specify the various column
names that you want to fetch from the
table we write the table name using the
from statement
next
we have the where clause to filter out
our table based on some conditions so
you can see here where condition 1
condition 2 and so on
then we have the group by clause that
takes various column names so you can
write group by column 1 column 2 and so
on
next we have the having clause to filter
out tables based on groups
finally we have the order by clause to
filter out the result in ascending or
descending order now talking about the
various data types in sql
so we have
exact numeric which has integer small
end bit and decimal
then we have
approximate numeric
which are float and real
then we have some date and time data
type such as date time time stamp and
others
then we have string data type which
includes car this varchar and text
finally we have binary data types
and binary data types have binary
var binary and image now let's see some
of the various operators that are
present in sql
so first we have our basic arithmetic
operators so you have addition the
subtraction multiplication division and
modulus
then we have some logical operators like
all and any or between exists and so on
finally we have some comparison
operators such as equal to not equal to
this greater than less than greater than
equal to or less than equal to not less
than or not greater than now let me take
you to my mysql workbench where we will
learn to write some of the important sql
commands use different statements
functions data types and operators that
we just learned
now let me now go ahead and open my
mysql workbench
so in the search bar i'll search for
mysql workbench you can see i'm using
the 8.0 version
i'll click on it and
here it says welcome to mysql workbench
and below under connections you can see
i have already created a connection
which says local instance then you have
the root the local host and the port
number
let me click on it
you can see the service the username is
root and i'll enter my password
and hit ok
now this will open the sql editor so
this is how the mysql workbench looks
like
here
we learn some of the basic sql commands
so first let me show you the databases
that are already present
so the command is so databases
you can hit tab to autocomplete i'll use
a semicolon
i'll select this and here on the top you
can see the execute button
so if i run this
below you can see the output it says
show databases seven rows are returned
which means
currently there are seven databases
you can see the names
all right
now
let's say i want to see the tables that
are present inside this database called
world
so i'll use the command use
world which is the database name
now let me run it so currently i'm using
the world database
so to display the tables that are
present in the world database i can use
the show command
and write show tables
give a semicolon and i'll hit ctrl enter
this time to run it
all right so you can see the tables that
are present inside this
world database so we have three tables
in total city country and country
language
now
if you are to see the rows that are
present in one of the tables you can use
the select command
so i'll write select star which
basically means i want to display all
the columns so star here means to
display all the columns
then i'll write my
from
the table name that is
city
so this command is going to display me
all the rows that are present inside the
city table
so if i hit ctrl enter
all right you can see the message here
it says
thousand rows were returned which means
there were total thousand records
present inside the city table
so here you can see there's an id column
a name column this country code district
and population
all right
similarly you can check the structure of
the table by using the describe command
so i'll write describe
and then
i'll give the
table name that is city now let's just
run it
there you go the field shows the column
name so we have id name country code
district population
type here shows the data type of each of
the columns so district is character 20
id is an integer population is also
integer
null says yes or no which means if no
then there are no null values if it's
yes which means there are null values in
your table
key here represents whether you have any
primary key or foreign key
and these are some extra information now
let's learn how to create a table in
mysql so i'll use the create table
command for this and before that
let me create a database
and i'll name it as sql intro so the
command is create
database
and i'll give my database name that is
sql underscore intro
let me keep a semicolon and hit control
enter
so you can see i have created a new
database
now
if i run this command that is show
databases you can see this
newly created database that is sql intro
if i scroll down
there you go you can see the name here
sql intro
okay now within this database we'll
create a table called employee details
now this will have the details of some
employees
so let me first show you how to create a
table
that will be present inside the sql
intro database
so i'll use the command create
table
and then
i'll give my
table name that is going to be employee
underscore
details
next
the syntax is
to give the column names so my first
column would be the name column which is
basically the employee name
followed by
the data type for this column since name
is a text column so i'll use
varchar
and i'll give a value of 25
so it can hold only 25 characters
okay
next
i also want the age of the employee
now age is always an integer
so i'll give int
okay
then
we can have the gender of the employee
so gender can be represented as f or m f
for female and m for male so i'm using
the car data type or character data type
and i'll give the value as one
then let's have the
date of join
or doj
and this is going to be of data type
date
all right
next
we'll have the city name that is the
city to which the employee belongs to
so again this is going to be varchar 15
finally we'll have a salary column
and salary will keep it as float since
salary can be in
decimal numbers as well
now i will give a semicolon
all right so let me just quickly run
through it so first
i wrote my create command then the table
which is also a keyword
followed by
the table name which is employee details
here and then we keep the column names
such as name age
this gender
date of join city and salary
for each of the columns we also gave the
data type
all right so let me just run it
okay
so here you can see we have successfully
created our first table
now
you can use the describe command to see
the structure of the table
i'll write describe emp underscore
details
if i run this
there you go
so under field you can see the column
names then you have the data types
null represents if
the table can accept null values or not
and these are basically
empty
and we haven't set any default
constraint
all right
moving ahead
now let's learn to add data to our table
using the insert command so on a notepad
i have already
written my insert statement so let me
just copy it and then i'll explain it
one by one all right
so if you see this
so we have used an insert into statement
or a command
followed by
the table name that is emp details
then this is the syntax using values i
have passed in
all the records
so first we have jimmy which is the name
of the employee then we have 35 it
basically represents the age
then m means the gender or the sex
then we have the date of join
next we have the city to which the
employee belongs to and finally we have
the salary of the employee so this
particular information represents one
record or a tuple
similarly the next employee we have is
shane
you can see the age and other
information
then we have
mary there's dwayne sarah and amy
all right
so let me go ahead and
run this
so this will help you insert
the values in the table that you have
created
you can see we have successfully
inserted six records
now
to display the records let me
use the select statement so i am using
select star from emp underscore details
if i run this
you can see my table here and the values
it has
so we have the name column the age
column the state of join city salary
and these are the values that you can
see here
moving ahead now let's say you want to
see the unique city names present in the
table
so in this case you can use the distinct
keyword along with the column name in
the select statement so let me show you
how you can print the distinct
city names that are present in our table
now if you notice this table clearly
we have chicago seattle boston austin
this new york and there's seattle
repeated again so i only want to print
the unique values
so for that i can write my select
statement as select
distinct
then i'll give my column name which is
city from
my table name that is emp details
if i run this
you can see
my query has returned five rows and
these are the values so we have chicago
seattle which was repeated twice is just
been shown once then we have boston
austin and new york
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let's see how you can use inbuilt
aggregate functions in sql
so suppose you want to count the number
of employees in the table in that case
you can use the count function in the
select statement so let me show you how
to do that
so i'll write
select
i'll use my function name that is count
now since i want to know the
total number of employees i am going to
use their name
inside the brackets from
employee underscore details
now if i run this
this will return the total number of
employees that are present in the table
so we have
6 employees in total
now if you see here in the result it
says count name now this column is
actually not readable at all
so what sql provides is something called
as an alias name so you can give an
alias to the resultant output so here
i can write select count of name
and use an alias as
as
i can give an alias as
count underscore name
and run this statement again
there you go you can see here in the
resultant
output we have the column name as count
name which was our alias name
now suppose you want to get the total
sum of salaries you can use another
aggregate function called sum
so i'll write my
select statement
and this time instead of count i am
going to write sum
and since i want to find the sum of
salaries
so inside the bracket i will give my
salary column
from
my table name that is employee details
if i run this
this will result in the total sum of
salaries
so basically it adds up
all the salaries that were present in
the salary column
now let's say you want to find the
average salary so instead of sum you can
write the average function which is avg
so this will give you the average salary
from the column salary so you can see it
here this says average salary now if you
want you can give an alias name to this
as well now you can select specific
columns from the table by using the
column names in the select statement
so initially we were selecting all the
columns for example like
you saw here
the star represents that we want to see
all the columns from the employee
details table
now suppose you want to
see only specific columns you can
mention those column names in the select
statement
so let's say i want to select
just the name
age
and the city column
from my table that is employee details
so this will result
in displaying only the name agent city
column
from the table if i run it there you go
it has given only three columns to me
now sql has a where clause to filter
rows based on a particular condition
so if you want to filter your table
based on specific conditions you can use
where clause now where clause comes
after
you give your table name
so suppose you want to find the
employees
with age greater than 30 in this case
you can use a where clause so let me
show you how to do it
i'll write select
star from
my table name that is
employee
details
and after this i'll use my where clause
so i'll write where
age
greater than
if i run this
it will give me the output where the age
is only greater than 30 so it excluded
everything that is less than 30.
so we have four employees whose age is
greater than 30 here
now suppose you want to find only female
employees from the table you can also
use a where clause here
so i'll write
select
let's say i want only the name the
gender which is
sex here
comma city
from my table that is employee details
where i'll give my column name that is
sex is equal to
since i want only the female employees
i'll give
f
and run this statement
okay you can see here
our employee table has three female
employees
now suppose you want to find the details
of the employees who belong to chicago
or austin in this case you can use the
or operator
now the or operator in sql displays a
record if any of the condition separated
by r is true
so let me show you what i mean
so since i want the employees who are
from chicago and austin
i can use
an or operator so i'll write select star
from
emp details which is my table name
then i'll give my where clause where
city
equal to
i'll give my
city name as chicago
and then i'm going to use the or
operator or
city
equal to
i'll write austin
i'll give a semicolon and let me run it
there you go
so in the output you can see all the
employees
who belong to the city chicago and
austin
now there is another way to write the
same sql query
so you can use an in operator to specify
multiple conditions
so
let me just copy this
and instead of using the or operator
this time i am going to use the in
operator
so i will delete this
after the where clause i am going to
write where city
and use the in operator
inside bracket
i will give my city names as chicago
and i want
austin so i'll give a comma
and write my next city name that is
austin
so this query is exactly the same that
we wrote on top
let me run this
you will get the same output there you
go
so we have jimmy and duane who are from
chicago and austin respectively
now sql provides the between operator
that selects values within a given range
the values can be numbers text or dates
now suppose you want to find the
employees whose date of join was between
1st of jan 2000 and
31st of december 2010
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write select star from
emp details
where
my date of join that is doj
between
i'll give my two date values that is
first of
jan
and
i'll give my
second value
the date value that is
31st of december 2010.
so every employee who has joined between
these two dates will be displayed in the
output if i run it
we have two employees who had joined
between
2000 and 2010 so we have jimmy and mary
here who had joined in 2005 and 2009
respectively
all right
now in where clause you can use the and
operator to specify multiple conditions
now the and operator displays a record
if all the conditions separated by and
are true
so let me show you an example i'll write
select
star from
employee details table
where
i want the age to be greater than 30
and i want
sex to be
male
all right so here you can see i have
specified two conditions so if both the
conditions are true only then it will
result in an output
if i run it
you can see there are
two employees who are male
and their age is greater than 30.
now let's talk about the group by
statement in sql
so the group by statement groups rows
that have the same values into summary
rows like for example you want to find
the average salary of customers in each
department
now the group by statement is often used
with aggregate functions such as count
sum and average to group the result set
into one or more columns
let's say
we want to find the total salary of
employees based on the gender
so in this case you can use the group by
clause
so i'll write select
let's say
sex
comma
i want to find the total sum of salary
as
i'll give an alias name let's say
total salary
from
my table name that is employee details
next i am going to group it by sex
ok
let me run it there you go
so we have two genders male and female
and here you can see the total salary so
what this sql statement did was first it
grouped all the employees based on the
gender and then it found the total
salary now sql provides the order by
keyword to sort the result set in
ascending or descending order
now the order by keyword sorts the
records in ascending order by default
to sort the records in descending order
you can use the desc keyword
so let's say i want to sort my employee
details table
in terms of salary so i'll write select
star from
emp underscore
details
and i'll use my order by clause on the
salary column
so this will sort
all the records
in ascending order of the salary which
is by default you can see
the salary column is sorted in ascending
order
now suppose you want to sort the salary
column
and display it in descending order you
can use this keyword that is desc
let me run it
you can see the output now this time the
salary is sorted in descending order and
you have the other values as well now
let me show you some basic operations
that you can do using the select
statement
so suppose i write select
and do an addition operation let's say
plus 20
and i'll give an alias name as addition
if i run this
it will give me the sum of
10 and 20 that is 30.
similarly
you can use
the subtraction operator
and you can change the alias name as
let's say subtract
let's run it
you get minus 10. now there are some
basic inbuilt functions
there are a lot of inbuilt functions in
sql but here i'll show you a few
suppose you want to find the length of a
text or a string you can use the length
function
so i'll write select and then use the
length function i'll hit tab to auto
complete let's say i want to find the
length of
country india
and i'll give an alias as total
length
if i run it
you see here it returns 5 because there
are 5 letters
in india
there's another function called repeat
so let me show you how repeat works
so i'll write select
repeat
let's say i want to repeat the symbol
that is at the rate
i'll put it in single quotes because it
is a
text character and i want to repeat this
character for
10 times
close the bracket
and let's run it
you can see here in the output it has
printed at the rate 10 times you can
count
it all right
now let's say you want to convert a text
or a string to uppercase or lowercase
you can do that as well
so i'll write select and use the
function called upper
let's say i want to convert
my string that is india to upper case
i am not giving in any alias name
if i run this
see my input was
capital i and everything else was in
small letter
in the output you can see it has
converted
my input to all caps
similarly you can change this
let's say you want to print something
lower case you can use the lower
function
let's say
this time everything is in
uppercase if i run it
it converts india to lowercase
now let's explore a few date and time
functions let's say you want to find the
current date there is a function called
cur which stands for current
and
this is the function i am talking about
which is current date
if i run this you will get the current
date
that is 28th of jan 2021
and let's say you want to extract the
day from a date value
so you can use
the day function let's say i'll use day
and i want to find the day from my
current date
if i run this
you get 28 which is today's day
now similarly you can also
display the current date and time
so for that you can use a function that
is called now
so this will return the current date and
time
you can see this is the date value and
then we have the current time
all right and this brings us to the end
of our demo session
so let me just scroll through whatever
we have learned
so first i showed you how you can see
the databases present in mysql then we
used one of the databases and checked
the tables in it then we created another
database called sql intro for our demo
purpose
we used that database and then
we created this table called employee
details with column names like name
integer the sex date of join city and
salary
i showed you the structure of the
database let me run this again so you
get an idea you can see this was the
structure of our table
then we went ahead and inserted a few
records so we inserted
records for six employees so you have
the employee name the age the gender the
date of join the city to which the
employee belongs to and the salary of
the employee
then we saw how you can use the select
statement and display all the columns
present in the table
we learned how you can
display the unique city names
we learnt how to use
different aggregate functions like count
average and sum
then we learned how you could display
specific columns from the table
we learnt how to use where clause
then we used an r operator we learnt
about
inoperator
the between operator
then we used an and operator to select
multiple
conditions
finally we learnt about group by order
by and some basic
sql operations in this session we are
going to learn two important sql
statements or clauses that are widely
used that is group by and having
first we'll understand the basics of
group by and having and then
jump into mysql workbench to implement
these statements so let's begin
first
what is group by in sql
so the group by statement or clause
groups records into summary rows and
returns one record for each group it
groups the rows with the same group by
item expressions and computes aggregate
functions for the resulting group
a group by clause is a part of select
expression in each group no two rows
have the same value for the grouping
column or columns
now below
you can see the syntax of group by
so first we have the select statement
and then followed by the column names
that we want to select
from we have the table name
followed by the where condition and next
we have the group by clause
and here we include the column names
finally we have the order by and the
column names
now here is an example of the group by
clause
so we want to find the average salary of
employees for each department
so here you can see we have the
employees table it has the employee id
the employee name
the age of the employee we have the
gender
the date on which the employer joined
the company then we have the department
to which each of these employees belong
to we have the city to which the
employees belong to and then we have the
salary in dollars
so actually we'll be using this
employees table on mysql workbench as
well
so if you were to find the average
salary of employees in each department
so this is how your
sql query with group by clause would
look like so we have selected department
and then we are using an aggregate
function that is avg which is average
and
we have chosen the salary column and
here we have given an alias name which
is average underscore salary which
appears in the output you can see here
from employees and we have grouped it by
department so here in the output you can
see
we have the department names and the
average salary of the employees in each
department now let me take you to my
mysql workbench where we will implement
group by and solve specific problems
okay so i am on my mysql workbench so
let me make my connection first
i'll enter the password
so this will open my sql editor
so first of all
let me
check the databases that i have
so i'll use my query that is show
databases
let's run it
okay
you can see we have a list of databases
here
i'm going to use my
sql underscore intro database so i'll
write
use
sql underscore intro
so this will take us inside this
database i'll run it
all right
now you can check the
tables that are present in sql
underscore intro database
if i write show tables you can see the
list of tables that are already present
in this database to do our demo and
understand group by as well as having
let me first create an employee table
so i'll write create table
employees
next
i'll give my column name as employee
underscore id which is
the id for each employee
i'll give my data type as integer and
i'll assign
employee id as my primary key
next i'll give
employee underscore name
and my data type would be
var car
i'll
give the size as 25
my third column would be the age column
age would obviously be an integer
then i have
my gender column
i'll use character data type and assign
a value of 1 or size of 1
next we have the date of join
and the data type will be date
we have the
department column as well this is going
to be of
var car
and
20 will be the size
next
we have the city column
which is actually the city to which the
employee belongs to
and finally
we have the
salary column which will have the
salary for all the employees
okay
now let me select and run this
you can see here we have successfully
created our table
now to check
if our table was created or not you can
use the describe command
i'll write describe employees
you can see
the structure of the table so far
all right
now it's time for us to insert a few
records into this employees table so
i'll write
insert
into
employees
and i'll
copy paste the records which have
already
written on a notepad so let me show you
so this is my emp notepad and you can
see i have already
put the information for all the
employees so let me just copy this
and
we'll paste it here
all right
let me go to the top and verify if
all the records are fine
all right
so let's run our insert query
okay so you can see here we have
inserted 20 rows of information
and
now let's check
the table information
or the records that are present in our
employees table
i'll write select star from employees if
i run it you can see here
i have my employee id the employee name
age gender
we have the city salary and in total we
have
instead 20 records
now
let me run a few sql commands to check
how the structure of our table is let's
say i want to see the distant cities
that are present in our table
so i'll write select distinct city from
employees
if i run this
you see here there are total eight
different cities present in our
employees table so we have
chicago the shuttle boston we have new
york
miami and detroit as well
now let's see
you want to know the
total number of departments that are
present so you can use distinct
department
if i run this
all right you can see we have seven rows
returned and here are the department
name so we have sales marketing product
tech i t finance and hr
all right
now let me show you
another sql command now this is to use
an aggregate function
so i want to find the
average age of all the employees from
the table
so i can write
select
avg which is the
aggregate function for average
inside that i have passed my
age column from employees if i run this
so the average age of all the employees
in our table is
33.35
now
say you want to find the average age of
employees in each department
so for this you need to use the group by
clause
i'll give a comment here i want to find
the
average age
in each department
so
i'll write select
department
comma
i'll write
average of age
from
employees
group by
department
now if i run this
you can see here
we have our
seven departments
on the left
and on the right you can see the average
age of employees in each of these
departments now you can see here
in the output it says avg of age which
is not readable so i can give an alias
name as
average age
all right
i can bring this down
and if you want you can round the values
also
so you can round the decimal places so
i'll use a round function before the
average function
and
the round function takes two parameters
one is the variable and
the decimal place you want to round it
to
so if i run this
there you go you can see here we have
the
average age of all the employees in each
of these departments
all right
now suppose
you want to find the total salary of all
the employees for each department
so
you can write select
department
comma
now i want the total salary so i'll use
the sum function
and i'll
pass my column as salary
from
employees
group by
department
let's run this query
you can see here in the output we have
the different departments
and on the right you can see the total
salary of all the employees in each of
these departments
now here also you can give an alias name
as
total underscore salary
let's run it again
and you can see the
output here
all right now moving ahead
you can also use the order by clause
along with the group by clause
let's say you want to find the total
number of employees in each city and
group it in the order of employee id so
to do this i can use my select query
i'll write select
count of let's say employee id
and i want to
know the city as well
from
employees
group by
city
and next you can use the order by clause
i'll write order by
count of
employee id
and i'll write desc which stands for
descending
if i run this query
you can see here
on the left you have the count of
employees
and on the right you can see the
city names so in chicago we had the
highest number of employees working that
was four then we had seattle houston
boston austin
and the remaining also had two employees
so in this case we have ordered our
result based on the count of employee id
in descending order so we have the
highest number appearing at the top and
then followed by the lowest okay
now let's explore another example
suppose we want to find the number of
employees that joined the company each
year we can use the year function on the
date of joining column then we can count
the employee ids and group the result by
each year
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select
i'm going to extract here from
the date of join column
i'll give an alias as year
next
i'll
count the
employee
id from my table name that is employees
and
i am going to group it by
year
date of join
i give a semicolon
all right
so let's run this
great
you see here in the result we have
the year that we have extracted from the
date of join column and on the right you
can see the
total number of employees that joined
the company each year so we have in 2005
there was
one employee similarly we have in 2009
there were two employees
if i scroll down you have information of
other years as well
now if you want you can
order this as well based on year or
count
okay now you can also use the group by
to join two or more tables together
so
to show you this operation let me first
create a sales table
so i'll write create
table
sales
and the sales table will have columns
such as the product id
which is going to be
of integer type
then we have the
selling price of the product
now this will be a
float value
then we have the quantity sold for each
of the
products so i'll write
quantity
quantity will of integer type
next we have
the state in which the item was sold
and state i'll put it as var car and
give the size as 20.
let's run this so that we'll create our
sales table all right
so we have successfully created our
sales table
next we need to insert a few values to
our sales table so i've already written
the records in a notepad let me show you
okay so here you can see i have my sales
text file let me just copy these
information
i'll just paste it on
the query editor
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this
insert command all right so you can see
here we have successfully inserted nine
rows of information
so
let me just
run it through what we have inserted
so the first
column is the product id column then we
have the selling price at which this
product was sold then we have the
quantity that was sold and in which
state it was sold so we have california
texas alaska
then we have
another product
id which is one two three
and these are the states in which
the products are sold
so let me just
confirm with the
select statement i'll write select star
from
sales
where on this you can see we have
successfully created our table
okay
now suppose
you want to find the revenue for both
the product ids one to one and let's say
one two three since we have just two
product id's here
so for that you can use the select query
so i'll write select
product id
next
i want to calculate the revenue so
revenue is nothing but selling price
multiplied by the quantity so i'll use
the sum function to find the total
revenue
and inside the sum function i'll use my
selling price column
multiplied by
my quantity column
i'll give this
an alias name as revenue
from
my table name that is sales
finally i'll group it by
product id
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
the two product ids one two one and one
two three and here you can see the
revenue that was generated
from these two products
all right
now let's see
we have to find the total profit that
was made from both the products one to
one and one to three so for that i'll
create another table now this table will
have the cost price of
both the products so let me create the
table first
i'll write create table
let's say the table name is c product
which stands for the cost price of the
products
i'll
give my first column as product id
this will be an integer
and i'll have my second column as cost
price
cost price will have floating type
values
let's run this
so we have successfully created our
product cost table
now let me
insert a few values into the c product
table so i'll write insert into
c underscore
product
i'll give
my values
for 1 to 1
let's see the
cost price was
270 dollars
for each
and next we have my
product as one two three
and let's say the cost price for product
one two three was
two hundred and fifty dollars
let's insert these two values okay
next we'll join our sales table and the
product cost table so this will give us
the profit that was generated for each
of the products
so i'll write select
c dot
product underscore id
comma
i'll write
sum
s dot cell underscore
price now here c and s are alias names
so if i subtract my
cost price from the selling price
that will return the profit that was
generated
i'll multiply this with s dot
quantity
close the bracket
i'll give an alias name as
profit
from
sales as s
so here s stands for the sales table
i am going to use
inner join
c
underscore product table
as
the alias name should be c
where
s dot
product underscore id is equal to c dot
product underscore id
we are using product underscore id
because
this column is the common column to both
the tables
and finally
i am going to
group it by
c dot product underscore id
all right
so let me tell you what i have done here
so i am selecting the product id
next i am calculating the profit by
subtracting the cost price from the
selling price and i have multiplied
the quantity column
i am using an inner join to connect my
sales and the
product cost table
and i am joining on the
column that is product id and i have
grouped it by c dot product id
let's run this there you go so here you
can see for product id one to one
we made a profit of
eleven hundred dollars
and for product id one two three we made
a profit of
eight hundred and forty dollars so now
that we have learnt group by in detail
let's learn about the having clause in
sql
the having clause in sql operates on
grouped records and returns rows where
aggregate function results matched with
given conditions only
so now having and where clause are kind
of similar but where clause can't be
used with an aggregate function
so here you can see the syntax of having
clause you have the select statement
followed by the column names from the
table name then we have the where
conditions next we have the group by
finally we have having
and at last we have order by column
names so you can see here we have a
question at hand
we want to find the cities where there
are more than two employees so you can
see the employee table that we had used
in
our
group by clause as well so if you were
to find the cities where there are more
than two employees so this is how your
sql query should look like
so we have selected
the employee id and we are finding out
the count using the count function
next we have selected the city column
from employees we have grouped it by
city
and then we have user having clause
so we have given our condition having
count of employee id should be greater
than 2.
so if you see the output we have the
different city names and
these were the cities where the
count of employees was greater than 2
all right so let's go to our mysql
workbench and implement how
having works
so suppose
you want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
000 dollars you can use the having
clause for this
so let me first run my table which is
employees
if i run this you can see we had
inserted 20 rows of information
and
the last column we had was salary so the
question we have is
we want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
thousand dollars
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write
select
department
comma
i'll use the aggregate function that is
average
salary
i'll give an alias name as
evg
underscore salary
from
employees
next we'll use the
group by clause and i want to group it
by each department
and then i am going to write my
having clause so in having clause i'll
use my condition that is having
average of salary
greater than
75 000
let's run it
and see the output there you go
so here you can see
there were total three departments in
the company that is sales finance in hr
where the average salary is greater than
75 000
okay
next
let's say you want to find the cities
where the total salary is greater than
200 000 dollars
so
this will again be a simple
sql query so i'll write select city
comma
i want to find the total salary so i'll
use the sum function
and i'll pass my column as salary as
i'll give a
alias name as total
from
employees
group by
city
and then i am going to use my having
clause
i will pass in my condition as having
sum of salary
greater than
two hundred thousand dollars
all right
so let's run this query
there you go
so
so the different cities are chicago
sheetel and houston where the total
salary was greater than two hundred
thousand dollars now suppose you want to
find the departments that have more than
two employees so let's see how to do it
i'll write select
department comma
this time since i want to find the
number of employees i'm going to use the
count function
i'll write count star
as
employee underscore count or emp
underscore count which is my alias name
from
employees
next i'll group it by
department
having
i'll give my condition
count star greater than 2
let's run this
okay
so you have departments such as sales
product tech and i t where
there are more than two employees
okay now you can also use a where clause
along with the having clause in an sql
statement
so suppose i want to find the cities
that have more than two employees apart
from houston
so
i can write my query as select
city comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
where
i'll give my condition city
not equal to
houston i'll put it in double quotes
since i don't want to see
the information regarding houston
i'll group it by
city
having
count
of employees greater than 2.
so if i run this query
you see we have information for
chicago and seattle only
and we have excluded the information for
houston
now you may also use aggregate functions
in the having clause that does not
appear in the select clause
so if i want to find the total number of
employees for each department that have
an average salary greater than 75
thousand dollars
i can write it something like this
so select
department
comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
group by
department
and in the having clause
i am going to provide the column name
that is not present in the select
expression so i'll write having
average salary
greater than
this is another way to use the having
clause let's run this
all right you can see we have department
sales finance and hr and you can see the
employee count where the average salary
was greater than 75 000
okay
so let me
run you from the beginning what we did
in our demo so first we created a
table called employee then we inserted
20 records to this table
next we explored a few sql commands like
dextent then we used average
and finally we started with our
group by clause
followed by
looking at how group by can be used
along with another table and we joined
two tables that was sales and product
cost table to find out the profit
then
you learned how to use the having clause
so we explored several different
questions and
learnt how to use
having an sql in this session we will
learn about joins in sql
joins are really important when you have
to deal with data that is present on
multiple tables
i'll help you understand the basics of
joints and make you learn the different
types of joints with hands-on
demonstrations on mysql workbench
so let's get started with what are
joints in sql
sql join statement or command is often
used to fetch data present in multiple
tables sql joins are used to combine
rows of data from two or more tables
based on a common field or column
between them now consider this example
where we have two tables
an orders table and a customers table
now the order table has information
about the order id which is unique here
we have the order date
that is when the order was placed then
we have the shipped date this has
information about the date on which the
order was shipped then we have the
product name which basically is the
names of different products
we have the
status of delivery whether the product
was delivered or not or whether it was
cancelled then we have the quantity
which means the number of products that
were ordered and finally we have the
price of each product
similarly
we have another table called customers
and this customer table has information
about the order id
which is the foreign key here
then we have the customer id which is
the primary key for this table we also
have the phone number customer name and
address of the customers
now suppose
you want to find the phone numbers of
customers
who have ordered a laptop
now to solve this problem
we need to join both the tables the
reason being the phone numbers are
present in the customers table as you
can see here
and laptop which is the product name is
present in the orders table which you
can see it here so using a join
statement you can find the phone numbers
of customers who have ordered a laptop
now let's see another problem where you
need to find the customer names who have
ordered a product in the last 30 days
in this case we want the customer name
present in the customers table and the
last 30 days order information which you
can get from the order date column that
is present in the orders table
okay
now let's discuss the different types of
joints one by one so first we have an
inner join
so the sql inner join statement returns
all the rows from multiple tables as
long as the conditions are met from the
diagram a verb you can see that there
are two tables a and b
a is the left table and b is the right
table
the orange portion represents the output
of an inner join
which means an inner join returns the
common records from both the tables
now you can see the syntax here
so we have the select command
and then
we give the list of columns from table a
which you can see here is the left table
followed by the inner join keyword and
then the name of the table
that is b
on
a common key column from both the tables
a and b now let me take you to the my
sequel workbench and show you how inner
join works in reality
so here
i'll type
mysql
you can see i have got
my sequel workbench
8.0 version installed i'll click on it
it will take some time to
open
okay
i'll click on this local instance
and here i'll give my password
okay
so this is how an sql editor on mysql
workbench looks like
so first of all
let me go ahead and create a new
database
so i'll write
create
database this is going to be my command
followed by the name of the database
that is going to be sql underscore joins
if i give a semicolon and hit ctrl enter
this will create a new database you can
see here one row affected
now
you can check whether the database was
created or not using show databases
command
if i run it
here you can see i have
sql joins database
created
now i'll use this database so i'll write
use sql underscore joins
okay
now to understand
inner join consider that there is a
college
and in every college you have different
teams for different sports such as
cricket football basketball and others
so let's create two tables cricket and
football
so i'll write
create
table
and my table name is going to be cricut
next
i'm going to
create two columns
in this table the first column is going
to be cricut
id
then
i'm going to give
the data type as int and use the auto
increment operator
i'm using auto increment because my
cricut id is going to be
my primary key
then i'm going to give
the name of the students who are part of
the cricut team
and for this i'll use
varchar data type and give the length as
30.
i'll give another comma
and
i'll assign my cricut id as primary key
within brackets i'll give
cricut underscore id
cricket id is nothing but a unique
identifier for each of the players like
you have roll numbers in college
okay
let me just run it
all right so we have successfully
created our cricket table
similarly let me just copy this and i'll
paste it here
i'll create
another table called football
this will have the information of all
the students who are part of the
football team
and instead of cricket i am going to
give this as football id
all right
and
the name column will have the names of
the students
i'll change my primary key to football
id
all right
let me run this ok
so now we have also created our
football table
the next step is to insert a few player
names into both the tables
so i'll write my insert into command
first let's load some data to our cricut
table
so i'll write cricket and
i'll give my
name column
followed by
values and here i'll give some names
such as
let's say stuart
give another comma
the next player i'll choose is let's say
michael
similarly i'll add a few more let's say
we have
johnson
the fourth player i'll take is let's say
hidden
and finally we have
let's say fleming
okay
now i'll give a semicolon and run this
okay so let me just check if all the
values were inserted properly for this
i'll use
select star from
table that is cricket if i run it you
can see i have created a table and have
successfully inserted
five rows of information
now similarly
let's
insert
a few student names
for our football table
so i'll change this to
football
and
obviously there would be students who
will be part of both cricket and
football team
so
i'll keep a few
repeated names let's say stuart
johnson and let's say hayden are
part of both cricket and football team
then we have let's say
langer
and
let's say we have another player in the
football team that is astral
i'll just run it
okay you can see there are no errors so
we have successfully
inserted values to our football team as
well
let me just recheck it
i'll write select star from
football
all right
so we have five players in the football
team as well
okay
now the question is
suppose you want to find the students
that are part of both the cricket and
football team in this case you can use
an inner join
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select star from
cricket
as i'm using an alias name as c which
stands for cricket
then i'm going to write inner join
my next table is going to be football
as f which is an alias name for the
football table
then i am going to use the on
command or operator
and then
i will give the
common
key that is name here so c dot name is
equal to f dot name
so based on this name column from both
the table my inner john operation will
be performed
so let's just run it
there you go so stuart johnson and
hayden are the only three students who
are part of both the teams
all right
now you can also individually select
each of the columns from both the tables
so let's say i write select c dot
cricket underscore id
comma
c dot name
f dot
football underscore id
comma
f dot name
from
i'll write
cricket as c
inner join
football as f
on
c dot
name
is equal to f dot name
now if i run this you see we get the
same output here as well
all right
now let's explore another example to
learn more about inner joins so we have
a database called classic models let me
first
use classic models
i'll run this
okay
now let me just show the different
tables that are part of classic tables
all right
so here you can see there are tables
like customers there's employees office
there's office details
orders payments products and product
lines as well
all right
so
let me use
my select statement to show
what are the columns present in the
products table
okay
so this product table has information
about different
product names you have the product code
now this product code is unique here
we also have the product vendor
a little description about the product
then we have the quantity in stock
buying price and msrp
let's see what we have in
product lines
if i run it you see here we have the
product line which is the
primary key for this table then we have
the
textual description for each of the
products this is basically
some sort of an advertisement
all right now suppose
you want to find the product code the
product name and the text description
for each of the products you can join
the products and product lines table
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my select statement and
choose my columns as product code then
we have
product name
and let's say i want the text
description
so i'll write this
column name
okay
then i'll use from
my first table that is
products
inner
join product lines
i can use using
the common key column that is product
line
close the bracket i'll give a semicolon
and if i run it
there you go so you can see the
different product codes
then we have the different product names
and the textual description for each of
the products
so this we did by joining the products
table and the product lines table
all right
now suppose you want to find the revenue
generated from each product order and
the status of the product to do this
task we need to join three tables that
is orders
order details and products so first let
me show you what are the columns we have
in these three tables we have obviously
seen for the products table now let me
show you for orders and order details
table
so i'll write select star from
orders fire on it you can see it has
information about the order number
the date on which the order was placed
we also have the shipment date we also
have the status column which has
information regarding
whether the order was shipped or
cancelled
then we have some comments column we
also have the customer number who
ordered this particular product
similarly
let's check what we have under order
details
so i'll write select star from
order
details if i run it
you can see it has the order number the
product code quantity of each product we
have the price of each product then we
have the order line number
okay
so using the product
orders and order details let's perform
an inner join
so i'll write select
o dot
order number
comma
o dot
status
comma
i need the product name which i'll take
from the products table so i'll write p
dot
product name
now here o
p are all
alias name for the tables orders
products and i'll use od for order
details comma
since we want to find the revenue
we actually need to
find the product of quantity ordered
into
price of each product so i'll use a sum
function and inside the sum function i
will give
quantity
ordered
multiplied by
the price of each item
i'll use an alias as revenue
then i'll use my
from clause
from orders as o
inner join
order
details as i'll use an alias name as od
on
i'll write
o dot
order number
is equal to
od dot
order number
i'll use another inner join
and this time we'll join the products
table so i'll write inner join
products as
p
on
p dot
product code
is equal to
od dot
product code
and finally i'll use the group by clause
and group it by order number
all right
let me run this
okay there's some mistake here we need
to debug this
it says
you have an error in your sql syntax
check the manual all right
okay i think the name of the tables is
actually orders and not order
all right now let's run it
okay there's still some error
it says
classic models dot product doesn't exist
so again the product name is
i mean the table name is products and
not product so let's run it again
all right there you go so we have the
order number the status
the product name and the revenue
this we got it using
inner join from three different tables
now talking about left joins
the sql left join statement returns all
the rows from the left table and the
matching rows from the right table so if
you see this diagram you can see we have
all the rows from the
left table that is a and only the
matching rows from the right table that
is b so you can see this
overlapped
region
and the syntax
for sql
left join is something like this so you
have the select statement and then you
give the list of columns from table e
which is your left table
then you use the
left join
keyword
followed by the next table that is table
b on the common key column so you write
a dot key is equal to b dot key
okay
now in our classic models database we
have two tables customers and orders so
if you want to find the customer name
and their order id you can use these two
tables so first let me show you the
columns that are present in
customers and orders
i think orders we have already seen let
me first show you
what's there in the customers table
okay so you can see we have the customer
number
the name of the customer then we have
the contact last name the contact first
name we have the phone number then
there's an address column there are two
address columns actually
we have the city name the state
and we have other
information as well and similarly we
have
our orders table
so i'll write select start form orders
so i'll write select star from orders
but on this you can see these are the
information available in the
orders table
okay
so
let's perform a left join where we want
to find the customer name and their
order ids so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
or let's say first we'll choose the
customer number comma then i want the
customer name so i'll write c dot
customer name
then we have the
order number column which is present in
the orders table and let's say i also
want to see the status
then i'll give my left table that is
customers
as c
left join
orders as o
on
c dot
customer number equal to
o dot
customer number
let's run it
okay again there is some problem
all right so the table name is customers
let's run it
so there's another mistake here this is
customer number so b is missing cool
let me run it
all right so here you can see we have
the information regarding the customer
number
then
the respective customer names we have
the order number and the
status of the shipment so if i scroll
down you'll notice one thing there are a
few rows you can see which have null
values
this means
for customer number 125 and for this
particular customer name there were no
orders
and similarly if i scroll down you will
find a few more null values
you can see here there are two null
values here for
customer number 168 169 there were no
orders available
all right
now to check those customers who haven't
placed any orders
you can use the null operator so what
i'll do is here
i'll just continue with this i'll use a
where clause and write where
order
number is
null
now let me run this
okay so here you can see there are
24 customers from the table
that don't have any orders in their
names
okay
now talking about right joins
so sql right join statement returns all
the rows from the
right table and only matching rows from
the left table so here you can see we
have our left table as a and the right
table as b
so the right join will return all the
rows from the right table and only the
matching rows from the left table
now talking about the syntax so here you
can see we have the select statement
followed by the select statement you
will have the list of columns that you
want to choose
from table a
right join table b on the common key
column from both the tables
all right
now to show how right join works i'll be
using two tables that is customers and
employees so let's see
the rows of data that are present in the
customer table first so i'll write
select star from
customers
let's run it so here you have the
customer number the customer name
then we have the phone number the
address of the customers
you also have the country to which the
customer belongs to the postal code
and the credit limit as well similarly
let's see
for the employees table
here i'll change customers to employees
let's run it
okay so we have the employee number the
last name the first name
we have the extension the email id
the job title
and also
reports to here means the manager
okay
so based on these two tables we'll find
the customer name
the phone number of the customer
and the email address of the employee
and join both the tables that is
customers and employees
so let me show you
the command so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
comma
then we have c dot
phone i'll give a space here
next
i want
the employee
number from the employee table so i will
write e dot
employee number
comma
e dot
email
from
customers as c
right join
employees
as e
on
e dot
my common key column is employee number
here so i'll write e dot
employee number
is equal to
c dot
we have
sales
representatives
employee number
and i'm also going to order it by
the employee number column
okay
so you can see i have
my customer name selected from the
customers table the phone number of the
customer then we have the employee
number and the email address
so let me run it
okay
there's some problem
all right so the table name is customers
actually
let's run it once again
there you go
so you can see here
we have
all the values selected from our right
table which is the employees table you
can see writes on employees which means
your employees table is to the right
and then we have the customer name and
phone numbers of
the customers from the customer table
which is actually your left table
so you have a few
employee numbers such as one zero zero
two this one zero five six we don't have
any customer name or phone numbers
okay so there's another popular join
which is very widely used in sql known
as self joins so self joints are used to
join a table to itself
so in our database we have a table
called employees let me show you the
table first
all right
so here you can see we have the employee
number the last name the first name of
the employee we have the email id
and here if you see we have a column
called reports2 now this you can think
of as
the manager column so the way to read is
for example
for employee number 1056
the manager is 1 0 0 2 so if you check
for 1 0 0 2 we have
day in murphy
then
if i scroll down
let's see for employee number
yeah for employee number 1102 the
manager is one zero five six so here you
can see
who is at one zero five six you have
mary patterson
similarly if i scroll down let's say for
employee number one one eight eight
we have
the manager as one one
four three now if i check the table at
one one four three we have anthony bow
so
so the employee julie ferelli reports to
anthony bow
all right
now suppose you want to know who is the
reporting manager for each employee so
for that you can use a self join
so let me show you how to join this
employees table
i'll write select
and then i'm going to use a function
called concat
within brackets i'll start with my alias
name that is m dot
then i'll write
last name
i'm going to concat last name
followed by a comma
then i'll have my
first name
i'll close this bracket
and then i'm going to give my
alias name let's say manager
comma
next
i'm going to concat
the same
last name and first name and this time
i'm going to use a separate alias let's
say
e which stands for employee so i'll
write e dot
last name
comma and within
single quotes
i'll
give my comma and then i'll write e dot
first name
i close this bracket i'll give an alias
as let's say
employee
from
i'll write
employees
as
e
inner join
employs
as
m
on
m dot
i'll use my
common key column as employee number so
i'll write
m dot
employee
number
is equal to
e dot
here i am going to use the reports two
column
and then
i'll
order it by
let's say manager
okay
now let's run this
there you go so you have your two
columns as manager and employee so for
employee louie bonder
the manager is zerat bonder
similarly if i scroll down
you have there are multiple
employees reporting to this particular
manager similarly we have our manager as
anthony bow and we have
different employees who are reporting to
this particular manager and so on
all right now moving ahead
now let's see what a full join is
so sql full outer join statement returns
all the rows when there is a match in
either left or right table now you must
remember that mysql workbench does not
support full outer join by default but
there is a way to do it
so
by default this is how the syntax of
full outer join looks like
now this statement will work on other
sql databases like microsoft sql server
but it won't work on mysql workbench
i'll show you the right way of using
full auto join on mysql workbench
so to show full outer join i am going to
first use a left join and then we'll
also use a right join and finally we'll
use a union operator so the union
operator is used to combine the result
set of two or more select statements
so first of all let me write
c dot
customer name so for this example i'm
using the customer table and the order
table
comma
o dot
order number
so i just want to know the customer name
and the
order number related to the customer
from
i have customers
as
c
left join
i'll write
orders as o on
c dot
customer number
is equal to
o dot
customer number
let me just copy this
and after this i am going to use my
union operator
so union operator is used to merge
results from
two or more
tables
so basically this performs a vertical
join
and next i am going to use my right join
operation
so here instead of left join i'll write
right
rest all looks fine
let me just run it
there you go so we have successfully run
our
full outer join operation you can see we
have the different customer names
and
the order that each customer had placed
in this session we will learn advanced
sql queries
so in this video we will learn some
queries in sql we'll also have a look at
stored procedures and learn about
triggers in sql we'll cover views in sql
and look at some of the important
windows functions in sql
now to learn all of these we'll be using
the mysql workbench on windows
so let's get started with sub queries in
sql
so let me head over to my mysql
workbench
so currently i am on my mysql workbench
let me connect to the local instance
so i'll give my password
i'll click on ok
all right so this is my
mysql workbench query editor so first we
are going to learn sub queries let me
give a comment
and write sub queries
all right
so first of all let's understand what a
subquery is so a sub query is a query
within another sql query that is
embedded within the where clause from
clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries so for that
i'll be using my
database that is sql underscore intro so
i'll write my command use sql underscore
intro
now this database has a lot of tables
i'll be using the employees table that
is present inside sql underscore intro
let me just expand this and you can see
here we have an employees table
so let me first show you
the contents within this table i'll
write select star from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee id employee name age gender
this
date of joint department city and salary
and we have information for
20 employees if i scroll down you can
see there are 20
employees present in our table
so let's say
you want to find the employees whose
salary is greater than the average
salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query
so let me show you how to write a sub
i'll write the select statement in the
select statement i'll pass
my column names that i want to display
so the column names i want are the
employee name
then i want the department of the
employee and the salary of the employee
from
my table name that is employees
next
i'll use a where condition
where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees
so i'll write salary greater than
after this i am going to write my sub
query
so i'll give
select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees and i'll
close the bracket and give a semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once we get the average salary number
will use this
where condition
where salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if i run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is
seventy five thousand three hundred and
fifty dollars
now
i want to display all the employees who
have salary greater than seventy five
thousand
three hundred and fifty dollars
so let's run our
sub query
there you go
so there are eight employees in our
table who have
a salary greater than the average salary
of all the employees
all right
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
john's salary
so we have one employee whose name is
john
let me
run the table once again
okay if i scroll down
you see we have an employee
as john
you see this
our employee id 116 is john and his
salary is
67 000
i want to display all the employees
whose salary is greater than john's
salary so basically all the employees
who are earning more than 65 thousand
dollars i want to print them
so let's see how to do it
i'll write
select
i want the employee name
comma the gender of the employee
i also want the department and salary
from
my table name that is employees
i'll write where
salary
is greater than
i'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket i'm
going to give my inner query that is
select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is
john
so within
single quotations i'll give john as my
employee
i'll end with a semicolon
so
let me first run my inner query
so this will give us the salary that
john has which is 67 000
now i want the employees who are earning
more than sixty seven thousand dollars
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see
12 rows returned which means there are
12 employees in our table who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars you see here
all these employees have a salary
greater than sixty seven thousand
dollars
okay
now
you can also use sub
queries with two different tables so
suppose you want to display some
information that are present in two
different tables you can use sub queries
to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a
database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic models i'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website i'll just show you the
website name so this is the website that
is mysql tutorial.org
you can see here they have
very nice
articles
blogs from where you can learn
my sequel in detail
so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website
you see here they have a mysql sample
database if you click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
mysql sample database
and the name of the database is classic
models all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session
if i expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have cricket
customers as employees
offers this orders order lines and many
more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products stable
first let me show you the content that
is present inside
the product table first
if i run this
you see here it says 110 rows return
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line
we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock by price
msrp
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the
details of all the orders
let me show you
the records
details tables has
okay so there are thousand records
present in this table you have the order
number the product code quantity ordered
price of each item you have the order
line number as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name
and the msrp of the products whose price
of each product is less than hundred
dollars
for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables
and we are going to write a sub query
okay
so
if you see here
in the order details table we have a
column called price each
i want to display the product code the
product name and the msrp of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way i'm going to do is
i'll write select
product code comma
product name
now one thing to remember
that this product name is actually
present inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is products and order
details here you can see this is the
product code column
comma
msrp which is present inside the
products table again
from my table that is
products
where
i'll write
product
code
i'm going to use the in operator
next i'll write my inner query that is
select
product
code from
my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than
100 dollars
let me run this
okay so you can see
there are total 83 products in our table
which have
a price
less than hundred dollars you can see
the
price here
okay
now
we learn another advanced concept in sql
which is known as stored procedures
i'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an sql code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
so if you want to write a query over and
over again save it as a stored procedure
and then call it to execute it
so in this example i want to create a
stored procedure that will return the
list of players who have scored more
than 6 goals in a tournament
so i have a database called
sql underscore iq
these are a few databases that have
already created
so this database has a table called
players if i expand the
tables
option you see we have a table called
players and you can see the columns
player id the name of the player the
country to which the player belongs to
and the number of goals each player has
scored in a particular tournament
so i'll write a stored procedure that
will return the list of
top players who have scored more than 6
goals in a tournament
so first of all let me begin by
using my sql underscore iq database
we'll run it
so now we are inside the sql underscore
iq database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are
six players in our table
we have the player id
the names of the players the country to
which these players belong to and the
goals they have scored
so i'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this
it should
start with a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter i'll write
amberson amber send
next i'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name
let's say i want to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin i'll write my select
statement
i want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from my table that is
players
where
i'll write goals is greater than
will give a semicolon
then
i'll end my
procedure with a
delimiter
that was double ampersand
next
i'll write
delimiter
and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
and there should be a space
okay
now let's run our
stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our stored procedure
now the way to run a stored procedure is
you need to use the
call method and give the procedure name
that is top underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon
let's execute it
okay there is some problem here
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure
the name of the column is goals and not
goal
let me create that procedure again
okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exist let's
just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll edit here as well
now let's create it again
okay
now to
call my procedure i'll write call
space followed by
the procedure name which is top
underscore clears
if i run this you can see
we have two players in our table who
have scored more than six goals so we
consider them as the top players in a
particular tournament
all right
now
there are other methods that you can use
while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using
in parameter
all right
so for this example i'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees
based on their salaries
so we have a table
in our sql underscore iq database which
is called employee details
i'm going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of join city
and salary
using this table i'll create a procedure
that will fetch or display the top
records of employees based on their
salaries
and will use the in parameter
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write
delimiter
this time i'm going to use
forward slash
i'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
sp for stored procedure
sort
by salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure i'll give my
parameter
in
i'll create a variable bar and assign a
data type integer
then i'll write begin
followed by my select statement but i'll
select the name
age
salary
from
my table name that is
emp details or employee details
i am going to order this by
salary
descending
and
i want to
display limited number of
records so i am using this
limit keyword and my variable var which
i
created here
i lend my select statement
i'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and i'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here
all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our
second stored procedure which is sp
underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not
here
you have an option
to see
the stored procedures let me just
refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore player
and top underscore players
okay
now let's call our stored procedure i'll
write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by
salary
and inside this i'll give my parameter
which was actually var and this var
we have used in
limit
let's say i want to display only the top
three records of the employees
who have the top three highest salaries
okay
so let me run it
there you go so ami sara and jimmy but
the
top three employees who have the highest
salary
so you saw how you could use the in
parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement
and we called our stored procedure and
passed in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select
statement inside a stored procedure you
can also use
other statements let's say
update
so i'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the
in operator twice
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be
forward slash
then i'll write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the
update salary name
i'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
i'll assign is varchar 20
i'll again use my in parameter i'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
i'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement i'll write
update
table name that is employee details
set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and i'll
and the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure if i repress this you
can see i have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay
now let's see
first of all i'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table
okay so we have six rows of information
let's say you want to update the
salary of employee
jimmy or let's say
mary
from 70 000 to
let's say 72 000
or let's say
80 000
so i'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary
and this time i'm going to pass in
two parameters the first parameter will
be the
employee name
and next with a comma i'll give my new
salary that i want to
so my
employee name let's say is
mary
and the salary i want
to be updated is let's say 80 000
i'll give a semicolon
and i'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go
if you see this
record
for mary we have successfully updated
the salary to 80 000
now moving ahead
we learn to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
we will create total employees as an
output parameter and the data type would
be an integer
the count of the female employees is
assigned to the output variable which is
total underscore emps using the into
keyword
let me show you how to write
a stored procedure using the out
parameter
so first i'll declare my delimiter
do forward slash
i'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be sp underscore
count
employees
and inside this i am going to give my
out parameter
and the variable name that is total
underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next i am going to write
begin
followed by
my select statement that is select
i want the
count of total employees
and the output i am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is emp underscore
details
where
sex
is equal to
f which means
female
i'll give a semicolon
next
i'll end it
with the dv limiter and i am going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is
colon
so let me tell you what i am doing here
i am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure i am going
to count the total number of female
employees that are present in our table
emp underscore details so i've used my
out parameter and i'm creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is integer here in the
select statement i am counting the names
of the employees
and the result i am storing it in total
underscore emps
i have
used my where condition where the gender
or the sex is female so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure
let's
refresh this
okay you can see we have our new stored
procedure
sp underscore count employees
now
to call it i'll write call
the name of the procedure that is count
underscore
sp underscore count
employees
within brackets i'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
f underscore emp
i'll give a semicolon
then i'll write
select
at the rate
f underscore
emp as
female employees
okay
so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first i'll
call my procedure and then we'll display
the total number of female employees you
can see in our table we have three
female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next topic in this
tutorial on advanced sql
now we are going to learn about triggers
in sql
so i'll give a
comment here
triggers in sql
so first let's understand what is a
trigger
so a trigger is a special type of stored
procedure that runs automatically when
an event occurs in the database server
there are mainly three types of triggers
in sql we have the data manipulation
trigger we have the data definition
trigger and login triggers
in this example we will learn how to use
a before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the students role
number the age
the name and the students marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero
so in case the marks are less than zero
our trigger will automatically set the
marks to a random value let's say 50
so let's go ahead and create our
table that is
students
all right
so i'll write create
table
student
now this table will have the student
role number
the data type is integer
it will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the
names of the students so the third
column would be
name
the data type would be variable
or varying character
size i am giving it as 30
finally we have the marks as floating
type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created our table
now
i'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time i'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is mark
underscore
let's say verify
i am going to use a before insert
trigger so i'll write before
insert
on my table name that is student
next i'll write for
each
row
if
new dot
marks
is less than zero
then
we'll set
new dot
marks
equal to 50
so this is my
condition first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0 will assign a value 50
to that student because
usually the marks are not less than 0 in
any exam
i'll write end if
semicolon and i'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command i'll run it
it says trigger already exists
in this case we need to update the
trigger name let's say
i'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for st
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is mark and
not marks
so here we need to change it as mark
instead of marks
all right
let's run it
okay
so we have created a trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so i'll write insert into student
i'll write
values
i'll give the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10
the name is say ruth
and the marks is let's say 75.0
give a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student role number is 502
age is 12
the name is let's say mike
and this time i'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma
we'll insert the third
record
for student role number 503
age is 13
the name is dave
and let's say the marks obtained by dave
is 90.
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
the age is 10
neem i'll enter as jacobs
and this time again i'm purposely
giving the marks in negative
12 point let's say 5.
close the bracket
and give a semicolon
and i'll run my insert statement okay so
we have
inserted four rows of information to our
student table
now
let me run
the select query i'll write select star
from student
if i run this you see the difference
there you go so
originally we had inserted
for 502 the marks was minus
20.5 and for 504
for jacobs the marks was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because
when we created our trigger we had set
our marks to 50 in case the marks were
less than zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name
in this case our trigger name is
marks underscore verify underscore st
i'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
you give this as a comment
okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial concept in sql which is very
widely used
this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of their own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
i'll give a
comment as views in sql
okay
now
to learn views i am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as i mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use
classic models so i'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models
so here
let me show you one of the tables which
is called customers so i'll write select
star from customers
okay
i missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name
customer number we have the address
state country and other information
now i'll write a basic view command
using this customer table
the way to write is i'll write create
view
followed by the view name which is cust
underscore details
then you write as
select
i am going to select a few
column names from my original customer
table which is this one so i need the
customer name
let's say i need the phone number
and the city so you have this
information here you have the phone
number
and the
city
all right
i'll write from my table that is
customers
if i run this
my view that is cust details will be
created
let's run it
there's some error here because the name
of the table is customers and not
customer
i'll give an s and i'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and to display the contents that are
present inside our view i can write
select star from followed by the view
name that is
cursed underscore details
let's run it
there you go so we have the customer
name
the phone number and the city of the
different customers that we have in our
table
all right
now let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that i am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table
i am talking about the products table
and the product lines table present
inside classic
models database
so before i start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
let's run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description
and there's some html description and
image
so
i'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing
create
view
followed by the view name that is
product underscore
description
as
i'll write
select
product
name
comma
then i'll write
quantity
in stock
i also want the msrp
now these three columns
are present inside the products table
and next from the
product lines table i want the text
description
of the products
so i'll write from
products table
i'll give an alias as p
followed by inner join
my other table that is
product lines as let's say pl
on
the common column that is product line
so p dot
product line
is equal to
i'll give a space
pl dot
product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables
and our view name is product underscore
description
let us run it all right so we have our
view ready
now let me
view
or display what is present inside our
product underscore description
view
i'll add select star from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock msrpn
textual descriptions of the different
products in the table
okay
now there are a few other operations
that you can perform let's say you want
to rename a view
instead of product underscore
description you want to give some other
name
so i'll just give a comment rename
description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement i'll write rename table
product
underscore description which is my
old name
i want to change this name to let's say
i'll give vehicle description since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so i'll write vehicle
description
ok
let us run it
all right so here you can see i have
renamed my
view
so here if i just refresh it
and i'll expand this you can see we have
the cursed details view and we have the
vehicle underscore description view
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel
or you can use a command let's say
i'll write display views is the comment
now to show all the views you can use
show
full tables
where
table underscore
type is equal to within single quote
i'll write view
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is
some error here let's debug the error
this should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
for that you can use the drop command
so i'll write drop
view followed by the view name let's say
i want to delete
customer underscore details or cast
underscore details view
i'll write drop view
cust underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the cust underscore
details view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about windows functions
now windows functions were incorporated
in mysql in the 8.0 version
so windows function in mysql are useful
applications in solving analytical
problems so using the employees table
present inside my sql underscore intro
database so we will find the total
combined salary of the employees for
each department
so
first let me switch my database to sql
underscore
intro database
i'll run it okay
i'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we will partition our table by
department and print the total salary
and this we are going to do using
some windows functions in mysql
so i'll write
select
i want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma
next i'll write
the sum of salary
over
i want to partition it by
department
so i'll write partition by department
which is dept
and i'll give an alias as
total salary
so that it will create a new column with
the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go
so here we have created another column
in our result that is total salary and
for each of the employees and the
respective departments we have the
highest salary so in finance the highest
salary of one of the employees was
155 000
similarly if i come down we have the
highest salary from hr
if i scroll further we have the highest
salary from it marketing product sales
and
the tech team
all right
now we'll explore
a function which is called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its partition
so let me show you how to
use the row number function
i'll write select
row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so i'll write order by salary
i'll give the
alias as row num
give a comma
and i want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee
from my table that is employees
and i'll order by
salary
so let's see how our row number function
will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a row num column and we
have
successfully given row numbers to each
of the records you can see it starts
from 1 and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first i'll create a table
i'll write create table
let's say i'll give a random name that
is demo
and let's say we have in this table the
student id which is of type integer and
we have the student
name
which is of type var car
the size is 20
i'll create
the small table with a few records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so i'll write insert
into
demo
values
i'll give 101
the name is
shane
give a comma
i'll insert the second student name 102
the name is
bradley
give a comma
this time
for 103 we have
two records
let's say the name of the student is
herat
we'll give a comma i'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated 103.
next we have 104
the name of the student let's say is
nathan
then again let's say for
the fifth student
which is kevin we have
two records
i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you i'll write select
star from demo
if you see this
we have a few information that are
duplicated in our table
that is for student id 103 and student
id 105
now i am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table i'll write
select student underscore id comma
student underscore name
i'll give another comma and write
row underscore
number
over
within brackets
i'll write partition
by
st underscore id
comma
st underscore name
okay
then i'll write
order by
st underscore id
close the bracket i'll give an alias as
row num
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here
okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right now if you see here there is
just one student in the name shane we
have one student in the name
bradley
but here if you see for hey earth
the second record it says two which
means there are two records for hirad
and if i scroll down there is one record
for nathan and there are two records for
kevin which means kevin is also repeated
okay
now
we are going to see another windows
function that is called rank function
in mysql
so the rank function assigns a rank to a
particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
ranked values when two or more rows have
the same rank
so first of all let me create a table
and the name of the table would be
a random name we'll give it as let's say
demo1
and it will have only one
column let's say variable a of type
integer
we'll create this table first
okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table which is demo one so i'll write
value
one zero one
one zero two
let's say one zero three is repeated
i'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
next we have one zero four
one zero five
we have one zero six
and
let's say one zero six is also repeated
finally we have
one zero seven
okay let me insert these values to my
table that is demo one okay this is done
now
if i write
select
var underscore a
and use my
rank function i'll write rank
over
then i'll
order by
my variable that is var underscore a
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo1
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if i run this there you go
so here if you mark
so for variable
a101
the test rank is one for one zero two
the test tank is two but
for this value which is one zero three
the test rank is repeated because there
was a repetition for one zero three
so we have skipped the rank four here
for one zero four the rank is five now
for one zero five the rank is six now
for one zero six again since the record
was repeated twice
we have skipped the eighth rank and
our rank function has signed the same
value which is seven for one zero six
and for the last value one zero seven
the rank is
nine
all right
now moving ahead we'll see
our final windows function which is
called
first value
so first value is another important
function in
mysql so this function returns the value
of the specified expression with respect
to the
first row in the window frame
all right
so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and i'll write
first underscore
value which is my function
and pass in my employee name
and then i'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
i'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is
employees
so let me run this and see how the first
underscore value function works
all right so in our table
joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was
115 000 dollars
so
the first value function populated the
same
employee name throughout the table you
can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the partition
i'll write select emp underscore name
comma
i want the department
and the salary
comma
i'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter i'll write
over
here i'm going to use partition
i'm going to partition it by
department
since i want to know the employee name
who has the highest salary in each
department
and i'm going to order by
salary
descending
and i'll give my alias again as highest
salary
from
my table that is employees
so let's
run this and see the difference in the
output
okay so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for finance
jack had the highest salary from hr it
was
marcus
similarly in it it was william
if i scroll down for marketing it was
john for product it was
alice who had the highest salary
similarly in sales we had joshua
and in tech we had angela
so this is how you can use the first
underscore value function using
partition
in this tutorial we will learn how to
work with databases and tables using sql
with python
to do this demo we'll be using our
jupyter notebook and the mysql workbench
you can see it here
so we will write our sql queries in the
jupyter notebook with python like syntax
if you don't have mysql or jupyter
notebook installed so please go ahead
and install them first
while installing the mysql workbench you
will be asked to give the username and
password let me show you
so i am on my mysql workbench so once
you connect it will ask for the username
and the password so i've given my
username as root and password you can
give
while installing it
we will be using the same user id or the
username and the password to make our
connection
so let's get started with our hands-on
demonstration part
first and foremost let me go ahead and
import the necessary libraries
i'll give a comment as import libraries
all right
so first
i'll import
mysql dot connector
next
from
mysql dot connector
i am going to import
my error
method or the error module
next
i want to import
pandas as pd
so let's run this
okay there is some error here
this should be capital e and not small e
all right
you can see i have imported my important
libraries
now
i'm going to create a function
that will help us
create a server connection
so i'll write my user defined function
by using the def keyword
i'll write create underscore
server underscore connection
this is going to be my
function name
and it will take in
three parameters first is the host name
next is the user name
and then we have the user password
all right
i'll give a colon
and then
in the next line i'm going to define a
variable
which is going to be connection and i'll
assign it to a value called none
now we'll be using
exception handling techniques to connect
to our mysql server
the try block lets you test a block of
code for errors and accept block will
handle the errors
so i'll write
try and give a colon and then
i am going to reassign the connection
variable
to
a method which is
mysql dot
connector
dot connect
now this
mysqlconnector.connect method sets up a
connection so it establishes a session
with the mysql server if no arguments
are passed it uses the already
configured or default values
so here
we are going to pass in
three parameters the first is the
hostname
i'll write host
equal to
hostname which is host underscore name
i'll give a comma
then i'll write
user
equal to
user underscore name
next will be my
password
and
i'll assign the value user underscore
password
all
right
now
i'm going to
use a print statement
and write
mysql
database
connection
successful
after this
i'll give my accept block
so i'll use the keyword accept
here
i'll write error as
err
give a colon and then i'm going to use
the print statement
here i'm going to use some
print formatting techniques using the f
letter
i'll write error colon
and i'll use curly braces
give err
and then
i'll close the
double quotes
after this
i'm going to
return
my connection
all right
let me give a comment here
we are going to assign our password
so we need to put our
mysql
terminal password
so this password you assign it while
installing mysql workbench
i'll write
p
w
and i'll give my password which is
simply
at the rate one two three four five
and then
i'm going to
give my database
name so i'll give
database
name
here
i'm going to write
db
equal to this is the database i want to
create which is going to be
mysql underscore python
let me just scroll this down
ok
now
i'll say
connection
equal to
i'll pass in my
user defined function name which is
create
server
connection
and the
parameters which are going to be
localhost that is my
hostname
my username which is root
and then i'll give pw
which is my password that is exactly
simply at the rate one two three four
five
let's just run it now
okay
there is an error here we need to remove
this
double quotation
all right
made another mistake here this this
should be root
okay you can see here mysql database
connection successful
all right
next
we are now going to create a database
that is mysql underscore python so i'll
give a comment create
mysql underscore
python
database again to create this database
i'm going to create another user defined
function
using the def keyword
i'll write
the function name as create
database
pass passing the parameters as
connection comma
query
give a semicolon
and in the next line
i'll write cursor equal to
going to make the connection so i'll
write connection dot
cursor
and i'll give the parenthesis
so this mysql's cursor of mysql
connector python is used to execute
statements to communicate with the mysql
database the mysql cursor class
initiates objects that can execute
operations such as the mysql statements
okay
next
i'm going to again use my
try and accept block so i'll write
try
give a colon and here i'm going to use
cursor dot
execute
within that i am going to pass in my
query
next i'll use a print statement
and the message i am going to display is
database
created
successfully
after this
i'm going to write my accept block
i'll write accept
error as err
give a colon and then i'll use a print
statement i'll write print
i'll use the
formatting again
error colon
and i'll write
within single codes i'll give curly
braces
err and then i'll close the double
quotes
next let's
use the variable
create
underscore
database
underscore query
and
here i'm going to write my
sql query to create the database so i'll
write create
database
and followed by that i'll give my
database name which is going to be mysql
underscore python
okay
after this
i'll call my function which is create
database
and i'll pass in the
parameters the first one is
connection
and next
the query is create underscore database
underscore query let me just copy it
and i'm going to paste it here
right so what i am doing here is
i am creating a new function
that is to create a new database with
the name
mysql
underscore python which you can see it
here
now this function takes in two
parameters connection and query
i'm using the connection dot cursor
function which is often used to execute
sql statements using
python language and then i have created
my try and excerpt blocks
so this try block statements will try to
create my new database which is mysql
underscore python
in case it fails to create the new
database
the excel block will work so here i am
writing my sql query to create a new
database which is create database
followed by the database name and i am
assigning it to a variable which is
create database query and then i am
calling my function create database and
passing in the two parameters connection
and
the query
all right so let's just run it
all right you can see here it has
created my database successfully
now
you can verify this by
checking the mysql workbench or the
mysql shell
you can see on the mysql workbench here
on the
left panel under schemas there is a
database called mysql underscore python
let me just expand it now we haven't
created any table so it's not showing it
now
the next step we are going to connect to
this database
so let's go ahead and connect to our
database that we have just created i'll
write the comment as connect to
database
now to connect to a database i'm again
going to create a user defined function
using the def keyword i'll write create
underscore
db which is for database underscore
connection
and the parameters it will take is the
host name
followed by the username
then we have the user password
and finally we have the
database name
[Music]
i'll give a colon
in the next line i'm going to create my
variable
which is connection and then i'll assign
it to a value
none
after this i'm going to use my
exception handling techniques so i'll
write my
try block first i am going to reassign
my connection variable
using the
mysql connector method so i will write
mysql dot
connector dot connect
so this method
will take in the
parameters
so first
it will take the
host name
i'll write
host equal to
host underscore name
i'll give a comma
next it will take the
user name so user equal to user
underscore name
give another comma
next
it will take the user password
i'll use pass wd equal to
user underscore
password
we'll give another comma
and this time
it is going to be the database name so
i'll write database equal to db
underscore name
now
let's use the print statement
and the message we are going to print is
mysql
database connection
successful
all right
finally
we'll write my
accept block
i'll write accept
error as err
give a colon and then i'll use the print
statement
f
within double quotes i'll write error
colon
within single quotes curly braces i'll
write err
and will close the double quotes
finally
this function
will return
the connection value
all right
let's run it and there you go
it has run successfully so we have
connected to our database
now
it's time for us to execute sql queries
i'll give another comment saying
execute
sql
queries
all right
now to execute our sql queries i'll use
another user defined function which is
execute
underscore
query
and i'll pass in the parameters as
connection and
query
give a colon
i'm going to write
cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
now this is used to establish a
connection and run sql statements
next we'll use the
try and accept block so i'll write try
cursor
dot
execute
this will take in one parameter which is
going to be my query
and then i'll write
connection
dot
commit
which is another method
now let's use the print statement
so i'll write
print
let's say the message would be
query was successful
and then
we'll write our accept block which is
accept
if the try block doesn't work throw an
error
using the print statement
within double quotes inside the
inside the curly braces i'll write err
and close the double quotes
all right so let's run it
okay so we have successfully created our
various functions that were needed to
create a database establish a connection
and to execute our queries
all right
now it's time for us to create our first
table inside the mysql underscore python
database
so to do that
i am going to write my
create command in sql
so first we are going to assign a sql
command to a python variable using
triple quotes to create a multi-line
string so let me show you how to do that
i'll write my
variable name
which is going to be create
orders
table it is always recommended to use
relevant variable names to make it more
readable
and now
i am going to use triple quotes
so the triple quote
will ensure
i can create my multiline string
inside the triple quote i am going to
write my
create command which is create table
here i am going to create an orders
table first
and inside the orders table i'm going to
create my
column names the first column would be
the order id
it is going to be of type integer and
i'll assign this order id as my primary
key column
we'll give a comma
next
the second column would be
customer
underscore name
the customer name column would be of
type
varying character so i'll write varchar
and i'll give a size of 30
and
this is also going to be
not null
moving ahead my fourth column would be
the product name column
so i'll write product underscore name
product name will be of type
varying character the size is let's say
and it is also not null
next
i am going to create my
fourth column which is the date on which
the item was ordered or the product was
ordered
so i'll write date ordered
the data type will be date
next
i'll create
a quantity column to keep track of the
number of quantities that were ordered
this is of type
integer
my next column would be unit price which
will basically have information about
the price of each unit of product
unit price can be of type float
and finally i'll have the phone number
of the customer
i'll write phone number phone number can
be kept as of type
varying character
i have assigned a size of 20.
now let's give a semicolon and
we'll
close the
triple quotes
all right
so this is how the syntax would look
like
next
to run this we are first going to
call our create db function so let me
give a comment as
connect to the database
i'll write connection
equal to
create underscore db underscore
connection
my parameters would be
my hostname which is localhost
my username which is root
comma my password
and then my database name which is mysql
underscore python so i'll write just db
all right
finally let's execute this query using
the execute underscore
query function that we have created
earlier
this takes in two parameter the first
one is connection
followed by
the variable name which is create
orders underscore table
let us run it
okay there is some error here let's see
what's the error
okay so here we have put four
double quotes this should be triple
quotes now let's run it
okay there is another here let's debug
it
it says name cursor not defined
let me just roll it to the above cell if
you see here in our
execute underscore query
function instead of
cursor
i have written cursor so r is missing
let's read on this and now let's run
this again
there you go you can see here mysql
database connection successful even our
query was also successful
now if you want to recheck if the table
that is orders was created or not you
can check it on the mysql workbench so
let me show you how to do it so i am on
my mysql workbench and under mysql
underscore python database you have
something called as tables let me just
right click and i'll select
refresh all there you go you can see
this arrow just click on this arrow
and here you can see we have a table
called orders so we have created a table
called orders
now you can check the columns as well
you have the order id you have the order
id the customer name product name
ordered
date quantity unit price and phone
number
now it's time for us to insert a few
records to this table which is orders
now to insert records i'll give a
comment as insert
data
i'll start with the
variable name let's say the variable
name is data underscore
orders i'll give triple quotes
next
i'll write my insert into command so
i'll write
insert into
my table name that is orders
followed by
values
and now i'll start entering
my records for each of the rows so first
i'll give 101 which is the order id
then i'll give the
customer's name let's say steve
and the product he had ordered is let's
say laptop
then i'll give my date in which the item
was ordered
let's say it is 2018
i'll choose
0 6 as the month and the date is let's
say
12. we'll give another comma this time
we'll pass in the quantity which is two
let's say the price of each
laptop phone number this is random let's
say 6 2
let's say
8 0 2
all right similarly i am going to insert
five more records of different customers
and their items that they have purchased
to this table orders
so here on my notepad i have my rest of
the five records let me just copy it and
we'll
paste it in the
cell here this will save us some time
okay
let me recheck if everything is fine
i'll give a comma here all right so we
have
six customers in our table which have
their customer ids from 101 to 106. you
have steve
jaws stacy nancy maria and danny you
have the different items they have
purchased laptop books trousers t-shirts
headphones and smart tv is the date on
which they had ordered this item the
number of quantities they had ordered
and then we have the unit price and some
random phone numbers
so let's
create the connection now i'll write
connection
equal to i'll write create
underscore db underscore connection
then i'm going to give my same
parameters let me just copy it from the
top which is localhost
host name
root is my username then we have
password and the database name
and then
i'll use the same query as above which
is execute query
i'll copy this
paste it here and instead of create
orders table variable i'll put as data
underscore orders
so this will store my
insert into command you can see the
variable i have used here is data
underscore orders
now it's time let's just run it
all right
there was some mistake here let's debug
it
again this should be triple quotes and
not
four now let me rerun it again there you
go you can see here mysql database
connection successful and my query was
also successful
now
we'll create
another user defined function which will
help us read query and display the
results
so i'll write
my function name as
df
read underscore
query
this will take in two parameters
connection and query
then i'll write
cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
i'll put my
result as none
and then i'll use my
try and accept block i'll write try
cursor dot
execute
this will take in one parameter which is
query and then i'll
give another variable which is result
equal to
cursor dot
fetch
all now this fetch all method will
return
all the
results in the table
i'll write return
result
next
we'll use the accept block
so i'll write accept
error as err give a colon and i'll use
my print statement
scroll this down
i'll use my formatting f
error
give a colon followed by a space
within single quotes
inside curly braces i'll give err and
close my double quotes
let's run it
all right
so now we are all set
now we are going to use our select
clause having whereby
then we'll see how to use order by
clause
some inbuilt functions we'll update some
records delete some records and do a lot
of other stuff
so
let's start with our first query
so our first query is going to be
using the
select statement
all right
so suppose
i want to display all the records that
we have inserted into our orders table
so the way to do is
i'll
assign my query to a variable let's say
q1
i'll give
triple quotes
within triple quotes i'll write select
star from orders
will give a semicolon followed by the
triple quotes
now we'll establish the connection so
let me just go to the top
and i'll copy this line which is to
connect to our database
i'll paste it here
now we'll
create a variable called results that
will store the result of this query
and we are going to assign this variable
to
our function that is read query and this
read query will have
two parameters the connection and the
variable name which is q1 for the query
next to display i am going to use a for
loop i'll write for
results
for result
in
results
print
i'll say result
now we are done
let's just run this query
there you go you can see here we have
successfully printed
all the rows in our table which is
orders you can see we have six records
in total
now we are going to explore a few more
queries so let me just copy this and we
are going to edit in the same query
i'll paste it here
next
let's say you want to display
individual columns from the table and
not all the columns so let me
let me create the variable q2
now instead of star i am going to
display only the customer name
and let's see the phone numbers of the
customers so i'll write phone underscore
number
all right the rest all remains the same
let me just recheck it and here instead
of
q1 we'll put q2
and
let's run this cell all right you can
see here now we have displayed only two
columns the first column is the customer
name and then we have the respective
phone numbers
okay
now let me just paste that query again
now we are going to see how you can use
an inbuilt function
that is
in our table we have the
order date and from the order date we
are only going to
display the different years that are
present in the order date
so to do that i am going to use the year
function
i'll add this query instead of q1 i'll
make it q3
and here i'm going to write select
here which is my function name from my
column which is date ordered
from orders and here i'll change this to
q3
q1 q2 q3 are basically query 1 query 2
and query 3. let's run it
there you go so we have successfully
extracted the different years present in
the order date column
now if you want to display the distinct
or the unique dates present in the
column
you
can use the extent keyword in the select
statement
so the way to do it is i'll write select
distinct
give a space
the rest of the query remains the same
and here instead of q3 i'll write q4
i'll make this as q4
let's run it
you can see 2018 and 2019 are the unique
year values that are present in the
order date column
okay
now moving ahead
let's write our fifth query and this
time we are going to explore how you can
use the where clause
so i'll change this to q5
before i write my query
so let's say you want to display all the
orders
that were ordered before
31st of december 2018.
so to filter this we are going to use
the where clause
so i'll write select
star
from orders
next i'll write where
my date underscore ordered
is less than
within quotes i will give my date value
which is 2018 december
31st
so all the items or the products that
were ordered before 31st of december
2018 will be displayed so let's run it
all right you can see here there are
three orders in our table which have
been ordered before
31st of december
now moving ahead
we want to display
all the orders that were made after 31st
of december
so here
what you can do is i'll just copy the
above query again i'll copy this line
so instead of less than
31st of december 2018 i'll make it as
greater than so every order that was
placed after
31st of december will be displayed
if you run it so you can see here there
are three orders in our table which were
ordered after 31st of december 2018.
now moving ahead
let's write our seventh query
now let's see
how the order by clause works in sql so
you can filter your results based on a
particular column or sort it based on a
particular column
so this is going to be my query 7
i'll write it from scratch again let's
say
you want to display all the columns from
the table so i'll write select star from
orders
then i'm going to use order by
unit price
i'll give a semicolon
let's run this query and see the output
now if you see the result here
and you mark the
unit price column
the result has been ordered in ascending
order of unit price you see here it
starts
with the lowest price and then
goes on with the highest price towards
the end now if you want to order it in
descending order you can use the keyword
desc
so this will ensure your top
or the most expensive products appear at
the top and the least expensive products
appear at the bottom
all right
next
now let's see how you can create a data
frame
from the given table
so as you know
using jupyter notebook and pandas you
can create data frames and work on it
very easily so with this table also we
can create our own data frame
so for that let me create an empty list
first i'll write from
db
equal to i'll assign this as an empty
list
so we are going to return a list of
lists and then create a pandas data
frame
next i'll write my for loop i'll write
for result in
results
i'll assign result
to
list of results so i'm converting the
result into a list
and then i'm going to append it to the
empty variable or the empty list which
is from underscore db dot
append
i'll append the result to
my empty list
next
we need to pass in the
columns now that will be part of our
data frame so i'll write
columns equal to
this column i'll pass it
within
a list so i'll give my first column as
order id
then we have the
customer name
next i have my
product name
then i have the date on which it was
ordered
give a comma then we'll have the
quantity column
let me write it in the next line
next we have the unit price column
and finally we have the
phone number column so i'll write within
double quotes
phone number
and this
we are going to assign it to a data
frame so i'll be using pd dot
data frame which is my function to
convert a list into a data frame
my variable i'm going to pass is from
underscore db
and i'll write
my next argument is columns equal to
my
variable name that is columns
finally let's display
the data frame which is df
all right
so here i am creating a empty list first
and then
i am creating a
for loop and i am appending the results
to my empty list here you can see i have
created my column
list
and using pd.dataframe i am converting
the list into a data frame
if i run this
this is
append and not appends
all right you can see we have our
data frame ready this is the index
column it starts from zero onwards and
then we have the different
column names
okay
now let's see how to use the update
command
now suppose
you want to
change the unit price of one of the
orders
you can use the update command so the
way to do it i'll first
create my variable let's say update
and i'll
give three
codes or triple quotes
then i'll use my update command which is
update followed by the table name that
is orders
next i'll write set
let's say unit underscore price
if you see this
let's say i want to set the unit price
of trousers from 50 to let's say 45
dollars i want to update this particular
record so i'm going to write set unit
price column
equal to
45 dollars where
the order id equal to
so this query will update the
third row in our table which is order
id103
so it will update from 50 to 45 dollars
i'll close the triple quotes
and now
i'll use the
connection
queries again
let me just paste it here
all right
i'll delete
these three lines of code and instead of
that i'll put execute underscore
query
and this will take in two parameters as
always which is going to be connection
followed by the variable name that is
update
let's run it you see here it says mysql
database connection successful query was
successful
now you can recheck that
to do it let me just go to the top and
we'll
just copy our first query which is q1
i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
let me just rename this now
this will be
q8
and i'll change this as well
i'll write select star from orders where
my order id equal to 103.
let's see the unit price of 103 now
you can see here instead of 50 now we
updated it to 45
all right
now the last command we are going to say
is how you can delete a record from the
table
i'll write delete command as my comment
now to delete a query
i'll first
give my variable name which is delete
underscore order
and i'll pass in within
triple quotes
next i'll write my delete query which is
delete from my table name that is orders
then i'll give my where clause where
let's say i want to delete my order id
105.
let me just go to the top and explain
you again
so if you see this we want to delete
the order id 105 which was for customer
name maria and she had ordered
headphones we want to completely remove
this particular record
so
i have my delete query ready
now let me just
create my connection and display the
results
so i'll go to the top and i'll copy this
connection command
which also has the execute query command
and i'll paste it here
and i'm going to make a change here
instead of update we'll write
delete underscore order
everything looks good let's just run it
you can see our query was successful
and now
if you want to
print it let me just show you
i'll just copy this
will paste it here
i'll make this as q9
i want to verify if
my order id 105 was deleted or not
instead of
the statement i'll write select star
from orders
and here i'll change this to q9
if i run this
you can see it here you can mark order
id 105 was deleted and it no more
appears in this table
all right
so this brings us to the end of the demo
session on sql with python let me just
scroll you through what we did so first
we imported the important libraries
mysql connector then we imported the
error function then we imported pandas
using pd
we learned how to create a server
connection to mysql database we created
a new database that is mysql underscore
python
and now we connected to that database
we created a function to execute our
queries we saw how you can write a
create table command
then we inserted a few records to our
orders table
we created a read underscore query
command to read the queries and display
the results
then we started exploring our
different sql commands one by one we saw
how to use
select query
then we selected a few individual
columns from our table
followed by using a
inbuilt function which was here then we
saw how to use the dixtend keyword
after that we used our where clause to
filter a table based on specific
conditions
we saw how to order your results based
on a particular column
then we saw how you could convert the
table into a data frame using
pd.dataframe function
finally if we learned how to use the
update command and the
delete command thank you all for
watching this live session on data
analysis using python and sql we hope it
was useful and interesting
if you have any queries then please feel
free to put them in the comments section
of the video thanks again stay safe and
keep learning